ओके
आई थिंक वी आर लाइव नाउ
ओके सो पहले मुझे बता दीजिए सभी लोग इफ आई
एम ऑडिबल क्लियरली मुझे एक बार बता दीजिए
इफ आई एम ऑडिबल आवाज आ रही है विजिबिलिटी
सही है बिल्कुल कोई प्रॉब्लम कोई दिक्कत
कोई इशू तो नहीं है सभी लोग एक बार जल्दी
से बता दीजिए फटाफट हरी अप गाइस
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
प्लीज लेट मी नो एवरीवन
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][खांसने की आवाज़]
ओके ऑल क्लियर चलिए अच्छी बात है ऑल
क्लियर है देन अच्छी बात है
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ओके ओके गाइस सो आई एम ऑडिबल क्लियरली नाउ
एंड विज़िबल एज वेल। सो जस्ट अ सेकंड मैं
यहां पे मोबाइल सेटअप कर लेता हूं।
ओके। गुड इवनिंग। गुड इवनिंग। गुड इवनिंग।
गुड इवनिंग। गुड इवनिंग टू एवरीबॉडी।
[हंसी]
नमस्ते।
गुड इवनिंग सर।
चलिए ओके। नमस्ते मुझे। ठीक है।
नितेश सर आप यहां पर आए टाइम निकालकर
क्लास के लिए। धन्यवाद।
हैप्पी बर्थडे टू यू सर। यह हैप्पी बर्थडे
कौन? हैप्पी बर्थडे। किसने बोला मेरा
बर्थडे है आज? ये किसने बोल दिया आपको?
किसने किसको बोल दिया कि मेरा बर्थडे है?
ये तो बताओ।
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
आई एम गुड। आई एम गुड। आई होप आप सभी ठीक
हैं।
सर डीडीएफएस डीसीआई के लिए वेट कर रहे
हैं। बिल्कुल जल्दी ही बैचेस आएंगी उसकी।
जल्दी बैचेस आएंगी। सभी को एक बार ज्वाइन
कर लेने देते हैं। देन वी विल बी
स्टार्टिंग नाउ।
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
ओके। सो सबसे पहले मैं आपको यहां पे
क्लियर करना चाहता हूं जो कि मैं हर
क्लासेस में बोलता हूं। सबसे पहले वेलकम
टू द क्लास 12 ऑफ दिस फ्री बट क्वालिटी
अबब्सोलुटली फ्री एंड क्वालिटी एसओसी एल1
ट्रेनिंग जो कि एक जॉब रेडी ट्रेनिंग होने
वाली है आपकी एंड आप कंप्लीट एल1 प्रोफाइल
के लिए रेडी हो जाएंगे इस पूरे ट्रेनिंग
के बाद अगर आप में सिंसियरिटी होगी उस
लेवल की एंड आपने उसी तरीके से चीजों को
फॉलो किया जैसे मैं आपको बता रहा हूं तो
डेफिनेटली यू आर गोइंग टू डू ग्रेट फॉर
एसओसीएल वन प्रोफाइल एंड आप उसके लिए रेडी
हो जाएंगे। दूसरी चीज जैसा कि मैंने हमेशा
बोला है कि आपको नेक्स्ट वीडियो नेक्स्ट
क्लास मैं तभी लाकर दे पाऊंगा जब आप
इसकीेंस समझेंगे। एंड उसके लिए आपको मैंने
पहले ही बोला था कि एटलीस्ट 200 प्लस
यूनिक कमेंट्स आपको करने हैं जो वीडियोस
होती हैं लास्ट उस पे। यानी ये वीडियो हो
गई। अब क्लास 13थ लाना हो तो 12th पे 200
प्लस यूनिक कमेंट्स होने चाहिए। कुछ लोगों
ने क्या किया था लास्ट क्लास के अंदर में
अह रिपीटेड कमेंट्स डाले बहुत सारे
अलग-अलग अह सेम आईडी से भी और डिफरेंट
आईडीज़ से भी। जब मैंने एक दो आईडीज पे
इन्वेस्टिगेशन कराया यूजर नेम पे तो उनका
कनेक्शन मतलब पता चला कि दे आर फ्रॉम सेम
दे आर फ्रॉम सेम पर्सन। ऐसी चीजें आप नहीं
करोगे। मैं आपसे पहले ही रिक्वेस्ट कर रहा
हूं क्योंकि उसको हम फिर भी अगर आपने 10
भी कमेंट करें हैं तो उसको हम सिंगल कमेंट
कंसीडर करेंगे। एंड उसी को काउंट करेंगे
एंड 200 जैसे ही कंप्लीट होंगे तभी
लाएंगे। तो मैं आपको पहले ही एक चीज
क्लियर करना चाहता हूं। तो ऐसे काम मत
करो। सिंगल सिंगल कमेंट करो। कोई फायदा
नहीं है मल्टीपल कमेंट्स करने का क्योंकि
आपका भी टाइम वेस्ट हो जाएगा। आप भी आपका
भी टाइम लगेगा और कमेंट कंसीडर सिर्फ
सिंगल होंगी। राइट? सो ये काम आप प्लीज मत
कीजिए। नाउ टोटल क्लास कितनी होगी? कोई
इसका लिमिटेशन नहीं है। जब तक कोर्स
कंप्लीट नहीं होता है, क्लासेस आपकी चलती
रहेंगी। एंड जब तक कोर्स कंप्लीट नहीं
होता है, तब तक मुझे भी नहीं पता कि कितनी
क्लासेस होने वाली है। ठीक है? तो उसके
पीछे मत जाइए कि कितनी क्लासेस होने वाली
हैं। क्योंकि यह कोई प्रीडफाइंड मैंने मैं
सोच के नहीं रखता कि मैं इतनी क्लासेस ही
कराऊंगा। उसके बाद चाहे जो भी हो जाए नहीं
कराऊंगा। जब तक ट्रेनिंग की रिक्वायरमेंट
होगी जब [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] तक
ट्रेनिंग चलेंगी तब तक जो है आपके
क्लासेस आते रहेंगे। सो आप सब इस चीज को
ध्यान में रखिएगा प्लीज कमेंट्स वाली
चीजों को। गुड इवनिंग। गुड इवनिंग।
नमस्ते। नाउ बिफोर स्टार्टिंग आज का टॉपिक
बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग है जो कि आपके लिए भी
काफी ज्यादा इंटरेस्टिंग होने वाला है।
डीडीओएस एंड एमआईटीएम के ऊपर हम आज बात
करने वाले हैं फॉर एसओसी मैन इन द मिडिल
अटैक एंड डीडीओएस डिस्ट्रीब्यूटेड एनाल ऑफ़
सर्विसेस। इसको थोड़ा हम प्रैक्टिकली भी
समझेंगे आज के सेशन में। थोड़ा सा ओवरव्यू
क्योंकि उतना डीप जाना नहीं है आपको बट
स्टिल वी विल बी गेटिंग अ वी विल बी
गेटिंग टू दैट। सो यहां पे मैं आपको फिर
से एक बार बताना चाहता हूं कि दो चीज़ हैं
जो आपको करनी है।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
पहले तो आपको किसी भी एसओसी की वीडियो ओपन
कर लेनी है। एंड देन इसके डिस्क्रिप्शन
में जाना है। यहां आपको दो लिंक मिलेंगे।
एक WhatsApp ग्रुप का मिलेगा और एक
WhatsApp चैनल का मिलेगा। दोनों को ओपन कर
लीजिएगा। WhatsApp ग्रुप जो है आपका
स्पेशल एसओसी के लिए ग्रुप बनाई गई है बाय
अस जहां पे आपको सारे एसओसी के रिसोर्सेज
जो भी नोट्स जो भी चीजें होती हैं वो शेयर
की जाती है। साथ ही में जो गिव अवे होने
वाली है अभी एक बहुत ही शानदार गिव अवे
उसकी भी अनाउंसमेंट यहीं पे उसी की
डिटेल्स यहां पे आएंगी। साथ ही आपके कोई
टेस्ट होंगे तो उसकी डिटेल यहीं पे आएगी।
सर्टिफिकेशन जो इस कोर्स को कंप्लीट करने
के बाद आपके लिए हम लेकर आएंगे उसकी भी
सारी डिटेल आपकी यहीं पे आने वाली है। तो
इसको जरूर जॉइ करना है। दूसरी चीज यह
हमारा WhatsApp चैनल है। इसको फॉलो इसलिए
करना है क्योंकि जो भी अपडेट्स आती है ना
वो सबसे पहले WhatsApp चैनल पे आती है।
चाहे वो ओवरऑल किसी भी चीज की अपडेट हो तो
आपको यह फॉलो कर लेना है। यह हमारा
Instagram हैंडल है डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी।
इसको फॉलो कर लीजिएगा फॉर इनेशनल रील्स
एंड कंटेंट्स। यह हमारा Twitter यानी एक्स
पेज है डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी हैंडल के साथ।
आप इसको भी जरूर फॉलो कर लीजिएगा। यहां पे
भी आपको कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग चीजें जो है वो
आने वाले टाइम में मिलने वाली है। बहुत
मजा आएगा आपको। देन आपकी हमारी वेबसाइट
है। इस पे आप हमें आके एक्सप्लोर कर सकते
हैं। हमारी एकडमी पे जाके हमारे
कोर्सर्सेस को एक्सप्लोर कर सकते हैं। और
यह हमारा जो है नंबर है जिस पे आप हमसे
कोई भी क्वेरीज, किसी भी तरह का कोई
क्वेश्चन हो तो आप हमसे पूछ सकते हैं।
दैट्स ऑल फॉर दिस। नाउ लेट्स बैक टू द
टॉपिक यहां पे। एंड Lindin पे अगर आप हैं
तो Lindin पे जो है आप बिल्कुल हमें फॉलो
कर सकते हैं। यह Lindin पे आप जैसे ओपन
करेंगे। सो दिस इज़ माय प्रोफाइल टेक्निकल
नेविगेटर ये वाली यूजरनेम ऊपर में आपको
लिंक मिल जाएगा। यहां पे आप मुझे फॉलो
करके कनेक्ट कर सकते हैं मुझसे। एंड साथ
ही में अगर आप डिफ़्रॉनिक्स सर्च करते हैं
तो आपको हमारी कंपनी का Lindin पेज
मिलेगा। जहां आपको अपडेट्स हमारी कंपनी के
रिगार्डिंग या जो भी हम आगे क्या कर रहे
हैं, कैसे कर रहे हैं, वह सारी चीजें जो
है आपको यहां देखने को मिलेगी। तो इसको
फॉलो जरूर कर लीजिएगा। जहां 22,000 से भी
मतलब लगभग 22 21,000 डिफ्रॉनिस्टर्स एंड
फॉलोअर्स जो है हमारे साथ जुड़े हुए हैं।
तो ये काम आप जरूर कर लीजिएगा। बस अब जो
है गाइस स्टार्ट करते हैं। आप देख सकते
हैं यहां पे
पीपल आर पोस्टिंग ऑन Lindin आल्सो। जैसे
यहां पे इन्होंने पोस्ट किया है लेटरल
मोमेंट एंड प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन जो
प्रीवियस क्लासेस हुई थी उसके ऊपर इन
इन्होंने काफी अच्छे से यहां पे की
पॉइंट्स जो है वो डाला हुआ है और उसके बाद
यहां पे एक डिटेल जो है यहां पे नोट्स का
पेज यहां पे 22 पेज का वो यहां पे डाला
हुआ है। ये काफी इंटरेस्टिंग है। इस तरह
के जो डिटेल्ड में लोग पुट डाउन करते हैं
यहां पे जब लिखते हैं तो मुझे काफी मजा
आता है। एंड आपके लिए काफी बेनिफिशियल
होगा आने वाले टाइम में। मैं आपको गारंटी
के साथ बोलता हूं जब आपका ये ट्रेनिंग ओवर
हो जाएगा फिर आपको एक्चुअल मजा आएगा
क्योंकि आप उन नोट्स के थ्रू उन पॉइंट्स
के थ्रू आप चीजों को रिवाइज एंड प्रैक्टिस
करेंगे एंड आपके लिए काफी इजी हो जाएगा।
सो यहां पे सभी लोग ऑलमोस्ट जॉइ हो चुके
हैं। हालांकि बहुत कम लोग अभी जॉइ हुए
हैं। बट स्टिल ठीक है। बट स्टिल लेट्स सी।
लेट्स सी लेट्स स्टार्ट एंड
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
आपने मेरा Lindin में रिप्लाई नहीं दिया।
मैं Lindin में कई लोगों के रिप्लाई नहीं
दे पाता हूं बट मैं देखता जरूर हूं
क्योंकि कई बार रिप्लाई नहीं कर पाता बट
आई डेफिनेटली वॉच। सो प्लीज कीप पोस्टिंग।
ठीक है? रिप्लाई मिले सिर्फ इसलिए पोस्ट
मत कीजिए। इसलिए पोस्ट कीजिए क्योंकि आपको
उसकी जरूरत है और आपके लिए वो बेस्ट है।
दैट्स इट। ठीक है? चलिए। ओके। सो यहां पे
प्लीज आप स्पैम मत कीजिए। सर मैंने अभी तक
नेटवर्किंग नहीं किया है। बेसिक कुछ भी ना
जानता हूं लेकिन मैं एसओसी में जॉब करना
चाहता हूं। तो क्या पॉसिबल है मुझे कोई
प्रोग्रामिंग भी नहीं आती। बिल्कुल आप जॉब
कर सकते हैं। सुबक्स इवन आप नेटवर्किंग का
नॉलेज आपको नहीं है। मैं आपसे एक चीज
बोलूंगा कि इस एसओसी सेशन में नेटवर्किंग
का भी कांसेप्ट आपसे डील किया जाएगा। आपको
बताया जाएगा। एंड हमारे चैनल पे नेटवर्क
सिक्योरिटी का एक प्लेलिस्ट है। आप उसको
जरूर फॉलो कर लीजिए। आपका नेटवर्किंग जो
है वो अच्छा हो जाएगा। चलिए आज की जो
टॉपिक है वो अपने आप में काफी इंटरेस्टिंग
टॉपिक है। बाकी सारे टॉपिक्स की तरह ही।
एंड आज जो हम करने वाले हैं टॉपिक वो है
एमआईटीएम एंड डीडीओएस। ये काफी इंपॉर्टेंट
है क्योंकि मैन इन द मिडिल अटैक भी हो
सकते हैं एक इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर के अंदर एक
नेटवर्क इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर के अंदर। एंड
डीडीओएस अटैक्स के चांसेस बहुत ज्यादा
होते हैं एक कंपनी के अंदर में। अब देखो
क्योंकि एज अ एसोसिएशन एनालिस्ट एल1 आप
फर्स्ट लाइन ऑफ डिफेंस कहलाते हैं। तो
आपका ही सबसे पहले काम बनता है उस
पर्टिकुलर अटैक के लिए शील्ड का काम करना।
एक शील्ड की तरह खड़े रहना एंड अटैक को
फर्दर स्प्रेड अप होने से रोकना। ठीक है?
ये आपका काम है। ये आपकी ड्यूटी रहेगी एज
अ एसओसी एल1 जो एनालिस्ट या जूनियर
सिक्योरिटी एनालिस्ट की तरह किसी भी
कंपनी।
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़] तो
आपको उस अटैक के बारे में बेसिक्स हर चीज
पता होनी चाहिए। बिल्कुल बेसिक स्कोरर
लेवल की चीजें पता होनी चाहिए। तभी तो आप
उसको डिफेंड कर पाओगे। इफ यू डोंट नो
एनीथिंग अबाउट एनीथिंग अबाउट समथिंग कुछ
भी आपको पता ही नहीं है तो आप कैसे उस चीज
के बारे में कोई भी काम कर सकते हैं आगे
चलके नहीं कर सकते। अगर आपको अपने टारगेट
के लिए इंफॉर्मेशनेशन गैदरिंग आपने
रिकॉग्निसेंस अच्छे से नहीं करी है तो आप
टारगेट के ऊपर फर्दर अटैक प्लान कैसे कर
सकते हैं? नहीं कर सकते। सिमिलर वे है एज
एसओ सीएल1 आपको फर्दर जो अटैक्स होने वाले
हैं टारगेट आप हैं और टारगेट करने वाले जो
अटैकर्स हैं तो उनका एक फ्यूचर अटैक प्लान
को समझ जाना एंड उसके लिए बेसिक कोर
कांसेप्ट्स को समझना बहुत-ब ज्यादा
इंपॉर्टेंट है। इस बात को आप सबको ध्यान
में रखना है। क्योंकि अगर आप उस चीज को
ध्यान में नहीं रखेंगे तो फिर समझिए कि
दैट्स वेरी वेरी दैट विल बी वेरी डिफिकल्ट
वेरी वेरी डिफिकल्ट।
तो
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़][अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
लेट्स बिगिन आवर जर्नी। यहां पर मैंने
मोबाइल पर भी आपका चैट ओपन करके रखा है
ताकि कभी-कभी मैं मोबाइल पर देख लेता हूं
क्योंकि यहां तो चैट दिखती नहीं है। सो
लेट्स स्टार्ट। एक बात याद रखिएगा जैसा कि
मैंने पहले भी बोला है आप सभी को कि इन
छोटी-छोटी टॉपिक्स के बारे में इन
छोटी-छोटे अ कांसेप्ट्स के बारे में जानना
उतना ही जरूरी है। उतना ही जरूरी है जितना
आपके लिए प्रैक्टिकल का जानना जरूरी है इस
एसोसियल वन के लिए। क्योंकि इनके अलावा
इनके बिना आप उन प्रैक्टिकल्स को ना तो
समझ पाएंगे और ना ही कंसेप्चुअली उनसे डील
कर पाएंगे। तो उस तरह की आपकी माइंडसेट
नहीं होनी चाहिए। मैं बस इतना ही चाहता
हूं।
सो लेट्स गो विद द एमआईटीएम मैन इन द
मिडिल। इसको बोलते हैं एमआईटीएम को मैन इन
द मिडिल एंड अटैक इज़ अटैक। ठीक है? तो मैन
मैन इन द मिडिल क्या होता है? मैन इन अ
मिडिल अटैक हैपेंस व्हेन एन अटैकर
सीक्रेटली इंटरसेप्ट्स कम्युनिकेशन बिटवीन
टू पार्टीज। बस सिंपल सा फंडा है। यहां पे
दो पार्टीज के बीच में कोई कम्युनिकेशन हो
रही है। उसको सीक्रेटली
क्या करना है? इंटरसेप्ट कर लेता है। कौन?
जो अटैकर है। इसको हम मैन इन द मिडिल अटैक
बोलते हैं। अटैकर की तरफ से। अब इसी का एक
एप्लीकेशन
है। इसी का एक एप्लीकेशन है। वो हम बाद
में डिस्कस करेंगे। बाद में उस पे बातें
भी करेंगे। बट मैन इन द मिडिल अटैक एक ऐसा
प्रोसेस है जिसके थ्रू दोस्त बात कर रहे
हैं। एक तीसरा बीच में आके उनकी बातें
सुनने लगता है। ठीक है? एंड उनकी बातों को
गैब करता है, सुनता है। तो वह जो तीसरा
बंदा है वह मैन इन द मिडिल है। बस इतना ही
है।
नॉर्मली क्या होता है? यूजर सर्वर से बात
कर रहा होता है। बट मैन इन द मिडिल के केस
में क्या होता है? उल्टा यूजर जो है सर्वर
से तो बात कर रहा होता है बट बीच में
अटैकर बैठा हुआ रहता है। दिस इज़ व्हाट मैन
इन द मिडिल अटैक डस। सिमिलर इस ग्राफिक्स
में आप देख सकते हैं। ये हमारा वर्ल्ड
वाइड वेब है। ये हमारा WW
है। एंड ये हमारे भैया यूजर भैया हैं। अब
यूजर भैया हमारेW
से कनेक्ट कर रहे हैं। बात कर रहे हैं। बट
बीच में हमारे जो ये अटैकर भैया हैं ये
इनकी ट्रांसमिशंस
से डाटा चुरा रहा है।
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
बस [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] ओके गौरव।
थैंक यू। यह हमारा मैन इन द मिडिल है। बीच
में से चुरा लेना। दैट्स इट। अब इसका एक
बहुत बड़ा इंपैक्ट होगा कि अगर कोई अटैकर
किसी नेटवर्क में एंटर हो चुका है, घुस
चुका है तो वो नेटवर्क के ट्रैफिक को
इंटरसेप्ट कर सकता है बहुत आसानी से। एंड
उससे जो सर्वर और यूजर के बीच बातें चल
रही हैं उसको वो सुन सकता है। यानी कि
उसको वो कैप्चर कर सकता है। उसको वो पढ़
सकता है। पैकेट्स जिसको बोलते हैं जो
पैकेट्स ट्रैवल कर रहे हैं। डेटा पैकेट्स
बोल लो, आईपी पैकेट्स बोल लो उनको दे कैन
रीड एंड दे कैन सी व्हाट्स एक्चुअली
कम्युनिकेशन इज़ ऑनगोइंग। इफ दैट
कम्युनिकेशन इज़ हैपनिंग ओवर एचटीटीp
यानी नॉन सिक्योर प्रोटोकॉल। किसी भी नॉन
सिक्योर प्रोटोकॉल या आपका टेनेट के ऊपर
हो रहा है, एचटीटीपी के ऊपर हो रहा है।
कोई भी [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] ऐसी
कम्युनिकेशन प्रोटोकॉल जहां पे सिक्योरिटी
नहीं है तो उन बातों को वो क्लियर टेक्स्ट
में पढ़ सकता है, समझ सकता है, देख सकता
है। एंड इनफैक्ट अगर एचटीटीपीएस पे भी हो
रही है तो देयर आर मल्टीपल वेज़ तरीके
क्या उसे? उन तरीकों से उन तरीकों से उसके
वो जो अटैकर आपका है वह उस नॉन
इंक्रिप्टेड चीज को उस पर्टिकुलर
इंक्रिप्टेड पार्ट को नॉन इंक्रिप्टेड में
कन्वर्ट कर सकता है और नॉन इंक्रिप्टेड
में कन्वर्ट करने के बाद वो क्या कर सकता
है? उस चीज को पढ़ सकता है। उस चीज को रीड
कर सकता है। तो देयर आर वेरियस टेक्निक्स।
एसएसएल स्ट्रिपिंग उस एक उसी टेक्निक के
अंदर का एक कांसेप्ट है। हालांकि वो डीप
कांसेप्ट दैट इज ऑन बेसिक इन साइबर
सिक्योरिटी। फिलहाल हम उस पे भी थोड़ा
बहुत डिस्कशन करेंगे। अब यहां पे आते हैं।
मैन इन द मिडिल का मेन गोल हमारा क्या है?
व्हाट इज द मेन गोल ऑफ़ मैन इन द मिडिल? यह
आपको एक सेकंड रुक जाइए। हां। यह आपको
समझना जरूरी है। गोल ऑफ़ मैन इन द मिडिल?
यहां पर कुछ मौसम बहुत ज्यादा खराब हो
चुकी है। बाहर का खतरनाक मौसम हो चुका है।
आंधी तूफान सब चल रहे हैं बाहर। अभी अचानक
से स्टार्ट हो गया है। मैंने सोचा क्या
आवाें आ रही हैं। सो इट्स हैपनिंग हियर।
राइट
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
या करेक्ट मिस्टर रोबोट। बिल्कुल सही बात
है। बिटर कैप पीटर कैप ये टूल्स है। मैन
इन द मिडिल का गोल क्या होता है?
क्रेडेंशियल्स को चुराना। सेशन कुकीज़ को
कैप्चर करना। क्योंकि कुकीज़ के अंदर
वेरियस इंफॉर्मेशनेशन स्टर्ड होते हैं।
अलग-अलग टाइप के इनेशन स्टर्ड होते हैं।
तो उन इंफॉर्मेशन को चुराना। मॉडिफाई डेटा
इन ट्रांजिट मतलब कि ट्रांजिट में जो डेटा
है कोई सा भी किसी भी तरह का डेटा है
ट्रांजिट में उसको मॉडिफाई करना यानी उसके
इंटीग्रिटी के साथ खिलवाड़ करना। इंजेक्ट
मैलवेयर मैल्वेयर्स को इंजेक्ट करना।
मॉनिटर सेंसिटिव कम्युनिकेशन। सेंसिटिव
कम्युनिकेशंस को मॉनिटर करना। तो ये सारे
काम मैन इन द मिडिल से हो सकते हैं। यही
गोल होता है अटैकर्स का। इसमें सबसे मेजर
गोल है हमारा क्रेडेंशियल्स को चुराना जो
अटैकर का ये होता है। सेशन कुकीज़ को
कैप्चर कर लेना ताकि ऑथेंटिकेशन से
रिलेटेड कुछ चीजें की जा सके या कुछ
वैरियस इंफॉर्मेशनेशन को भी चुराया जा
सके। एंड सेंसिटिव कम्युनिकेशन को मॉनिटर
करना जो काफी सारे केसेस में कई बार
गवर्नमेंट एजेंसीज भी करती हैं। जब उनको
नेशनल सिक्योरिटी का कोई मैटर लगता है,
कुछ ऐसा होता है तो किसी नेटवर्क में वो
पेनिट्रेट करके एंड ये काम किया जाता है।
ठीक है? अब गोल के बाद हमारा मेन मोटिव है
एमआईटीएम के अ टाइप्स को समझना। देयर आर
डिफरेंट-डिफरेंट टाइप्स ऑफ एमआईटीएम एंड
इन द मिडिल के बहुत अलग-अलग टाइप्स होते
हैं। उनको हम समझते हैं शॉर्ट में क्योंकि
यह जो टाइप्स मैं आपको बता रहा हूं ये
अपने आप में एक बहुत बड़े-बड़े टॉपिक्स
हैं इन एथिकल हैकिंग। एथिकल हैकिंग में ये
बहुत बड़े-बड़े टॉपिक्स हैं। इसीलिए अगर
आप एक एसओसी एल1 के लिए प्रिपेयर कर रहे
हो और अगर आपका साइबर सिक्योरिटी का
पोर्शन पहले से अच्छा है तो आपको तो काफी
इजी होगा चीजों को समझना। और बिल्कुल बट
मैं ऐसा मान के चल रहा था कि ऐसे भी
कैंडिडेट्स होंगे ना जिनका साइबर
सिक्योरिटी उतना कुछ खास अच्छा नहीं होगा।
टॉपिक्स उनके उनके बारे में उनको ज्यादा
आईडिया नहीं होगा। तो उनको ओवरव्यू देना
उनको बताना जरूरी है ना कि ये चीज है
क्या? नहीं तो फिर तो वो पीछे रह जाएंगे।
उनको पता ही नहीं चलेगा कि एग्जैक्टली हो
क्या रहा है। उनके दिमाग में चीजें काम
करनी बंद कर जाएगी। इस वजह से मैं बहुत
बेसिक और बिगिनर लेवल से चीजों को करा रहा
हूं। हर एक टॉपिक को इंक्लूड कर रहा हूं।
इस वजह से यह ट्रेनिंग इतना लंबा मैंने
बोला था 3-4 महीने। अदरवाइज एसओसी की
ट्रेनिंग में 3- महीने नहीं लगते। 2 महीने
में आपका सारा काम हो जाता। बट क्योंकि
मैं यहां पे साइबर सिक्योरिटी नेटवर्किंग
मैं यहां पे लinक्स की कांसेप्ट्स को
Windows के कांसेप्ट्स को इंक्लूड करके ला
रहा हूं। आपके सामने लाने वाला हूं। और भी
जो टॉपिक्स हैं। इस वजह से थोड़ी ये
ट्रेनिंग लंबी हो जा रही है। अदरवाइज और
भी कम देर में कम टाइम में हो जाती है
कंप्लीट आपकी। तो यहां पर आपको उस चीज को
थोड़ा सा गैब करना है, समझना है। एंड जब
भी मैं कोई एक-एक टॉपिक बताता हूं, मैं
आपको पहले ही बोल चुका हूं। आई हैव ऑलरेडी
टोल्ड अबाउट दिस थिंग कि जब भी मैं कोई
आपको टॉपिक डील करता हूं। जैसे अब मैं
आपको यहां पे क्या डील कर रहा हूं?
एमआईटीएम के टाइप से डील कर रहा हूं।
मैंने यहां पे एक टॉपिक लिखा है एआरपी
स्पूफिंग। अब एआयपी स्पूफिंग का मैं
ओवरव्यू दे दूंगा। बट थोड़ा सा डीप आपको
भी जाना है अपने साइड से। बहुत डीप नहीं
जाना है एयर स्पूफिंग में। नहीं तो दिमाग
चक्कर खा जाएगा। बट थोड़ा समझ लीजिए कि
एआरपी स्पोफिंग क्या एग्जैक्टली कैसे काम
करता है। बस हो गया। उसी को मैं बहुत
बेसिक तरीके से आपको समझाने वाला हूं कि
एग्जैक्टली ये होता क्या है? बस इतना करना
है। दैट्स इट। तभी तो मैंने बोला कि जितनी
क्लासेस अभी तक हो चुकी हैं उतने में ही
अगर आप डीप में घुस घुस के एक्सप्लोर कर
करके करते जाए ना तो आपको टाइम लगेगा वो
समझने में। टाइम लगेगा उसको खत्म करने
में। आई डोंट नो कितने लोग कर रहे हैं। बट
मुझे लगता है काफी लोग कर रहे
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] हैं। काफी
अच्छा। Lindin पे पोस्ट देखता हूं मैं।
अच्छा लगता है।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
देखो एआरपी प्रूफिंग में क्या होता है।
अटैकर ट्रिक्स डिवाइसेस इनू थिंकिंग आई एम
द राउटर। सो ट्रैफिक गोज़ थ्रू द अटैकर।
एग्जांपल फ्लो क्या है? विक्टिम अटैकर
राउटर इंटरनेट।
ये पूरा विक पूरा फ्लो है।
अब इसको समझते हैं। अटैकर ट्रिक्स
डिवाइसेस इनू थिंकिंग आई एम द राउटर।
तो जब हम एयर पीस प्रूफिंग की प्रैक्टिकल
कराते हैं अपने
डीसीएसपी वगैरह में डीसीजीएसपी में भी
डाला हुआ है तो उसमें किस तरीके से बताते
हैं वो वो अलग मतलब प्रैक्टिकल वे में वो
चीज आपको बताई जाती है लेकिन लेकिन यहां
पे आपको समझना जरूर है क्योंकि आप एसओसी
एनालिस्ट एनालिस्ट एल1 होते हुए आपको किसी
तरह का कोई डेमोंस्ट्रेशन वहां हैकिंग चीज
नहीं करनी है भाई वो यू आर अ ब्लू टीमर।
यू हैव टू सेफ गार्ड। यू डोंट हैव टू
अटैक। आपको नेटवर्क पे अटैक वटक नहीं करना
है। बट आपको अटैकर क्या-क्या कर सकता है?
अटैकर पर्सपेक्टिव भी समझना है। तो इस
पर्टिकुलर एआरपी स्पोफिंग टेक्निक में
क्या होता है जो कि मैन इन द मिडिल अटैक
का एक पार्ट है। अटैकर जो नेटवर्क में
डिवाइसेस होते हैं, उनको यह फील कराने
लगता है। उनको यह बताने लगता है कि मैं ही
राउटर हूं। अब सोचो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] सोचो मेरे
नेटवर्क में मेरे नेटवर्क में ये फोन है।
मेरे नेटवर्क में एक और फोन है। मेरे
नेटवर्क में एक लैपटॉप है। मॉनिटर है। सब
कुछ मान लो इंटरनेट से कनेक्टेड है। अब
इनको अगर ये कम्युनिकेशन नॉर्मली मेरा फोन
अगर इंटरनेट से कनेक्ट होता है तो
कम्युनिकेट कैसे करता है? मुझे बताइए।
किसी भी किसी भी नेटवर्क के अंदर में आपका
जो मान लो कोई डिवाइस है जैसे मेरा फोन है
या मेरा लैपटॉप है यह नेटवर्क बाहर के
इंटरनेट से मैं अगर YouTube से कनेक्टेड
हूं बाहर में YouTube के सर्वर से तो कैसे
कनेक्टेड हूं पहले मेरे लोकल नेटवर्क से
मेरे राउटर तक रिक्वेस्ट जाती है और राउटर
फिर बाहर की दुनिया से कनेक्ट करता है
सिंपल सा फंडा है। तो यहां पे ट्रैफिक
राउटर के हो राउटर के थ्रू होते हुए जाती
है। राउटर एक टनलिंग का काम करता है।
राउटिंग का काम करता है। रूट करता है आपके
रिक्वेस्ट्स को। आपके डेटा पैकेट्स को रूट
करता है। इधर से उधर लेकर जाता है। अंदर
से बाहर बाहर से अंदर। ठीक है? आपके
नेटवर्क सेडब्ल्यूडब्ल्यू
से आपके नेटवर्क तक। तो ये राउटर ही करता
है सब कुछ। यानी ट्रैफिक राउटर के थ्रू हो
के जा रही है। तो अटैकर क्या करता है?
एआरपी स्पूफिंग अटैक के थ्रू एआरपी टेबल्स
के अंदर कुछ ऐसा
छेड़खानी करता है कि जो डिवाइसेस हैं उनको
लगने लगता है कि रियल राउटर राउटर नहीं है
बल्कि अटैकर का जो डिवाइस है वही राउटर
है। अब जैसे ही डिवाइसेस को यह समझ में
आएगा कि अटैकर का डिवाइस ही राउटर है। तो
अब जो भी कम्युनिकेशन होगी अलग-अलग
डिवाइसेस के बीच में वो किसके थ्रू हो के
जाएंगी? वो अटैकर के डिवाइस से होके
जाएंगी। एंड वहीं पर हटाकर उसको इंटरसेप्ट
करता है। एंड उसके बाद आगे के प्रोसेससेस
इंटरसेप्ट करने के बाद डेटा के साथ जो भी
पोस्ट इंटरसेप्टिंग प्रोसेससेस होते हैं
क्रेडेंशियल्स चुराना हो गया, सेशन कुकीज़
को कैप्चर करना हो गया या इंजेक्शन हो गई
कुछ भी वो करता है। यही कहलाता है हमारा
एआरपी स्पुफिंग। जिसमें विक्टिम होता है।
देन अटैकर राउटर बन जाते हैं हमारे और
इंटरनेट तक। विक्टिम इंटरनेट तक डायरेक्ट
ना पहुंच के अटैकर को एज अ राउटर समझते
हुए अटैकर के थ्रू होके जाता है। बस दिस
इज़ कॉल्ड एआरपी स्पूफिंग अटैक जहां पे
एड्रेस रेोल्यूशन प्रोटोकॉल को स्पूफ किया
जाता है। एआरपी का मतलब होता है एड्रेस
रेोल्यूशन प्रोटोकॉल। जैसे
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] आपका डीएनएस
होता है ना इंटरनेट से जब आप डोमेन एंटर
करते हैं अपने ब्राउज़र में Google.com तो
डीएनएस उस डोमेन को मैप करता है
कॉस्पोंडिंग IPपी एड्रेस पे और आपका जो
ब्राउज़र है उस IP से कनेक्ट करती है
क्योंकि ब्राउज़र को भाई नहीं पता क्लाइंट
को पता ही नहीं है कि क्या होता है
google.com Yahoo.com, facebook.com दे
डोंट नो एनी अल्फाबेट्स। दे नो ओनली द
डिजिट्स दैट इज़ कॉल्ड IP एड्रेस। तो
डीएनएस जो होता है डोमेन नेम सिस्टम उसका
काम होता है उस डोमेन को IP पे मैप करना।
उसी तरीके से नेटवर्क के केस में एआरपी
होते हैं एड्रेस रेोल्यूशन प्रोटोकॉल जो
फिजिकल एड्रेस
पे मैप्ड IPपी एड्रेसेस पे मैप करते हैं
IP एड्रेसेस को। सिंपल
मतलब कि ये IP किस मैक का है? कौन सा मैक
बिलोंग करता है इस आईपी को? वह बताता है
आपका एड्रेस रेोल्यूशन प्रोटोकॉल उसका
टेबल होता है। जैसे डीएनएस का टेबल होता
है। एक तरफ IPपी एक तरफ डोमेन होती है।
उसी तरीके से एआरपी में आपका एक मैक
एड्रेस होता है। एक IPपी एड्रेस होती है
कि ये पर्टिकुलर आईपी किसका है?
बस।
तो जब एआरपी जो एड्रेस रेोल्यूशन
प्रोटोकॉल है जब ब्रॉडकास्टिंग होती है
उसमें तो ब्रॉडकास्टिंग होती है तो उसमें
पूछा जाता है अरे भाई ये आईपी किसका है?
बताओ नेटवर्क में यह आईपी किसका है? सारे
डिवाइसेस बताओ भाई यह आईपी किसका है? तो
एक डिवाइस बोलता है मेरा है भाई मेरा।
अच्छा अच्छा आपका है क्या? ठीक है। ठीक
है। तो दिस इज़ एआरपी एंड दिस इज़ कॉल्ड
एआरपी पोइजनिंग या एआरपी स्पोफिंग। आर यू
गेटिंग द कांसेप्ट इन द मोस्ट सिंपलर वे?
समझ में आया आपको? एआरपी स्पूफिंग क्या
होता है? बताइए मुझे। एवरीवन प्लीज लेट मी
नो। हाउ
डिड यू गेट व्हाट इज एआरपी स्पूफिंग?
जल्दी बताइए। फटाफट बताइए।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके
रिपीट तो नहीं कर सकते हैं। इट्स
इंपॉसिबल। पूरे कांसेप्ट को रिपीट नहीं कर
सकते। आप दोबारा वीडियो देख लीजिएगा। आप
लेट अगर जॉइन हुए होंगे तो देखो अगर आप
में से कोई लेट जॉइन होता है तो उन बंदों
के लिए रिपीट नहीं हो सकती है क्योंकि वो
तो फिर टाइम टाइम किल हो जाएगा ना टाइम
वेस्ट हो गया वो एक तरह का है ना तो आपको
वापस से वीडियो देखना पड़ेगा दैट्स ये
आपकी गलती है अगर आप लेट आते हैं मैं आपसे
यही बोलता हूं कि आप टाइमली ज्वाइन करिए
वो ज्यादा बेटर है ठीक है
तो वापस से वीडियो को देखिएगा।
बिल्कुल। सो मोस्टली पीपल हैव अंडरस्टुड।
हाउ शुड वी आंसर दिस इन इंटरव्यू इफ वी
वांट टू आंसर इट इन वन लाइन? सिंपल सा
सिंपल सा फंडा है। सिंपल सा फंडा है।
एआरपी स्पूफिंग अगर कोई पूछे तो स्पुफिंग
ऑफ एआरपी एड्रेस रेोल्यूशन प्रोटोकॉल बाय
एन अटैकर वेयर अटैकर
कन्विंस द डिवाइसेस ऑन अ नेटवर्क टू थिंक
इटसेल्फ एज अ राउटर एंड ट्रैफिक गोज़ थ्रू
द अटैकर्स डिवाइस। दिस इज़ कॉल्ड एआरपी
स्पोफिंग। सिंपल सा फंडा है। इसको सिंपल
आपको बताना है। एकदम सिंपल वे में बताना
है। इंटरव्यू में आप जितना सिंपल और जितना
टेक्निकल रहेंगे उतना ही ज़्यादा आपका बेटर
रिस्पांस माना जाता है। बस
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
ठीक है? चलिए आई थिंक काफी लोगों को समझ
में मैक्सिमम मैक्सिमम क्या सबको समझ में
आ चुका है। कुछ लोग लेट आए हैं तो
उन्होंने बोला है रिपीट करने को तो वो तो
पॉसिबल बिल्कुल भी नहीं है क्योंकि वो
टाइम वेस्ट हो जाएगा। राइट? आप प्लीज इसको
रिपीट मोड में देख लीजिएगा। रिकॉर्डिंग को
देख लीजिएगा रिपीट करके। ठीक है? एसओसी
इंडिकेटर्स जो है आपको क्या कह क्या क्या
बतलाएंगे? डुप्लीकेट मैक एड्रेसेस क्योंकि
क्योंकि डुप्लीकेट मैक एड्रेस वहां पे
बताएंगे क्योंकि अटैकर जो है उन्हीं
डिवाइसेस उन्हीं नेटवर्क के डिवाइसेस के
किसी एक डिवाइस को मिमिक कर रहा होगा या
करने की कोशिश करेगा। वह दिखाएगा कि मैं
तो इसी नेटवर्क का पार्ट हूं। कहीं बाहर
से नहीं आया हूं। इसी क्योंकि अब जो एआरपी
प्रोटोकॉल जब वह ब्रॉडकास्ट करेगी ना यह
आईपी किसका है किसका है तो जो ओरिजिनल मैक
एड्रेस वाला सिस्टम है डिवाइस है वो तो
बोल सकता है बट यहां अटैकर क्या करेगा
अटैकर ने क्या किया खुद उस मैक एड्रेस का
कॉपी बना लिया खुद का यानी कि मैक
स्पोफिंग कर ली मैक स्पोफिंग का मतलब होता
है मैक एड्रेस को कॉपी करना यानी कि एक
नेटवर्क में एक डिवाइस का मैक एड्रेस है
सेम मैक एड्रेस खुद का रख लेना दिस इज द
थिंग
एआरपी [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] टेबल चेंज
जैसे कि मैंने बोला एआरपी टेबल के अंदर
में भैया मैक एड्रेस आईपी एड्रेसेस की
लिस्ट आपको मिल जाती है तो उसमें चेंजेस
करना यानी कि एक पर्टिकुलर मैक एड्रेस को
जिस आईपी से बाइंड करना चाहिए जिस आईपी को
जिस मैक से बाइंड करना चाहिए तो किसी और
मैक से बाइंड कर देना दिस इज़ एआरपी टेबल
चेंजेस सडन ट्रैफिक रीराउटिंग सडनली
ट्रैफिक रीराउट होने लग रहा है ओरिजिनल
राउटर से ना जाके एक दूसरी किसी डिवाइस के
थ्रू ट्रैफिक जाने लग रहे इंटरनल नेटवर्क
एनोमलीज़ इंटरनल नेटवर्क में कुछ मतलब
एनोमेलिज़ कुछ इशूज़ जो है आपको देखने को
कुछ अलग तरह के डिफरेंट वियर्ड चेंजेस
देखने को मिल रहा है। ये सारी चीजें होती
है। अब एआरपी [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] और
एआरपी स्पोफिंग को बहुत
अ डीप में जाके आपको नहीं समझने की जरूरत
पड़ेगी। थोड़ा ओवरव्यू बस ले लीजिएगा।
दैट्स दैट्स इट। वो सॉर्टेड है आपका।
एसओसी एल1 प्रोफाइल के लिए आपको बस उतना
ही नॉलेज की जरूरत है। बहुत डीप नहीं जाने
की जरूरत है। ठीक है? बस इतना ही बोलूंगा।
बहुत अच्छी बात है। अब यहां पे
आगे की तरफ चलते हैं। जहां पे और भी कुछ
टाइप्स हैं मैन इन द मिडिल अटैक के।
जिसमें एक और टाइप आता है डीएनएस
स्पोफिंग। डीएनएस स्पुफिंग का थोड़ा बहुत
हमने ऑलरेडी एक दो बार जिक्र किया हुआ था
यहां पे। अटैकर रीडायरेक्ट्स डोमेन टू फेक
आईपी। जैसे एआरपी स्पोफिंग में अटैकर क्या
करता है? एक फेक मैक एड्रेस पर ट्राई करता
है रीडायरेक्ट करने का, आईपी को बाइंड
करने का उससे। उसी तरीके से डीएनएस में एक
डोमेन को फेक आईपी से बाइंड कर दिया जाता
है। वो आईपी किसकी होगी? वो अटैकर की आईपी
होगी। सिंपल। एग्जांपल Google सर्वर
को किस पे अह मैप किया गया? अटैकर के
सर्वर पे। वेरी सिमिलर टू फार्मिंग।
फार्मिंग में भी इसी तरह का कुछ होता है।
तो यहां पे डीएनएस स्पुफिंग में बेसिकली
फार्मिंग का कांसेप्ट ही वही था। डीएनएस
स्पूफिंग डीएनएस को लेके अ करना। राइट? तो
यहां पे अटैकर एक
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] डोमेन को एक फेक
आईपी पे कन्वर्ट कर देता है। मतलब एक फेक
आईपी पे रीडायरेक्ट कर देता है। अब सोचो
ना मैं जा रहा हूं google.com खोलने। और
वहां पर जो मेरा डीएनएस सर्वर है जो
डीएनएस है वह Google.com के IP पर ना
कन्वर्ट ना फॉरवर्ड करके उस डोमेन को किसी
अटैकर कंट्रोलोल्ड सर्वर पे फॉरवर्ड कर दे
तो हो गया फिर कहानी खत्म। फिर वहां पे तो
क्या हो सकता है? फिर तो गई भैंस पानी
में। फिर तो मैं कनेक्ट हो जाऊंगा किसी और
ही और उस सर्वर पर मान लो Google का ही
एकदम सिमिलर दिखता हुआ एक फर्जी वेब पेज
होस्टेड है जिसको फिशिंग पेज बोलते हैं वो
होस्टेड है तो आपको क्या लगेगा आपने
Google.com खोला वहां पे आपको उतना ध्यान
कई लोगों को ध्यान भी नहीं जाएगा कि अरे
Google.com ही तो ओपन किया है। क्या ही
टेंशन है? Google.com ही तो ओपन किया है।
तो वही ओपन होगी। बट वहां पे बैकग्राउंड
में कोई और ही Google का पेज ओपन दिख रहा
है। आपने एड्रेस बार पे उतना ध्यान नहीं
दिया। आपने क्रेडेंशियल्स डाला, फिशिंग हो
गई। आपके क्रेडेंशियल चुरा लिए गए खत्म।
दिस इज़ कॉल्ड डीएनएस स्पोफिंग। वेरी
वेरीरी डेंजरस।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके। चलिए अब आते हैं एसएसएल स्ट्रिपिंग
जो कि इसी का एक पार्ट है। जैसा मैंने
पहले ही बोला एसएसएल स्ट्रिपिंग एक
कांसेप्ट है। जहां पे एसटीपीएस को एसटीp
पे डाउनग्रेड कर दिया जाता है। देयर आर
टूल्स। एसएसएल स्ट्रिपिंग के टूल्स आते
हैं जिनका यूज़ किया जाता है। जहां पे
एचटीटीपीएस कम्युनिकेशन अगर हो रही है
किसी नेटवर्क के भी मतलब कोई मान लो आपने
वेबसाइट ओपन किया वो एचटीटीपीs पे काम कर
रहा है। अब आपने क्या किया? एसएसएल
स्टपिंग टेक्निक यूज़ किया और उसको http पे
डाउनग्रेड कर दिया। तो देयर आर टूल्स जैसे
एटरcp बिटर कैप ये टूल्स हैं
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] आपको काली या
लinक्स किसी भी लinक्स में आप यूज़ कर सकते
हैं। आप इन टूल्स के थ्रू ये काम कर सकते
हैं। हां अब ये बात अलग है कि कुछ
वेबसाइट्स प्रॉमिनेंट वेबसाइट्स जैसे कि
Facebook हो गई, Microsoft हो गया, Google
हो गया। इन पे हो सकता है ये
हर बार सही से काम ना करें और हो सकता है
कि कई बार काम कर भी जाए। डिफरेंट-डिफरेंट
अप्रोचेस होते हैं क्योंकि दे आर यूजिंग
एचएसटीएस अह सिक्योरिटी जो बोलते हैं अह
एचएसटीएस। एचएसटीएस के कारण थोड़ी सी
दिक्कत आ जाती है इनके डाउनग्रेडिंग में।
बट नॉर्मली बहुत सारी वेबसाइट्स जो है
एचएसटीएस यूज़ नहीं करती है। एंड एचएसटीएस
के बाद भी देयर आर अ चांसेस टू
डाउनग्रेडेड टू गेट डाउनग्रेडेड फ्रॉम
https टू hटीtp।
तो HTTP पर डाउनग्रेड जब हो जाता है तो
सिंपल सा लॉजिक यहां पर HTPS का खत्म हो
जाता है। एचटीपीएस का मतलब क्या है? हाइपर
टेक्स्ट ट्रांसफर प्रोटोकॉल एंड एस का वो
छोटा सा एस क्या होता है? मुझे बता दीजिए।
एवरीवन आई वांट टू नो जो एचटीडीटीपीs में
एस है उसको क्या बोलते हैं? वो क्या होता
है? प्लीज लेट मी नो गाइस। व्हाट इज द एस
इन एसटीडीटीपीएस? चलिए मैं चार्ट देख रहा
हूं। देखते हैं।
लेट सी हाउ मेनी ऑफ यू आर आंसरिंग करेक्ट।
ओके लेट्स सी
सिक्योर सिक्योर सिक्योर ठीक है ठीक है
काफी लोगों ने यहां पे सिक्योर बोला है
सिक्योर [खांसने की आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ठीक है चलिए अच्छी बात है यहां पे
एचटीटीपीएस में जो
ओके। https में जो एस है इस ये स्टैंड
करता है एसएसएल के लिए। मेनली एसएसएल के
लिए आप समझ लीजिए कि वो इसका मतलब एसएसएल
है। हालांकि वो सिक्योर होता है। राइट यू
आर देखो जिन्होंने सिक्योर बोला उन्होंने
भी सही बोला है। वो गलत नहीं है।
वो गलत नहीं है कि वो सिक्योर बोल रहे
हैं। बट यहां पे इसका मतलब समझिए। दिस इज़
यूजिंग द एसएसएल प्रोटोकॉल। दिस इज़ यूजिंग
द एसएसएल जिसको हम बोलते हैं सिक्योर
सॉकेट लेयर।
ठीक है? जिसको हम बोलते हैं सिक्योर सॉकेट
लेआउट जहां पे यूज़ हो जाती है ये एसएसएल
टेक्निक। हालांकि यह एक अब पुरानी टेक्निक
है जो डिप्रिसिएट कर दी गई है। अब इसकी
जगह पर टीएलएस यूज़ होता है जिसको हम बोलते
हैं ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर सिक्योरिटी
जिसको हम बोलते हैं ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर
सिक्योरिटी। सो दिस इज एसएसएल जो अभी
एसएसएल का मतलब सिक्योर सॉकेट लेयर यानी
कि एक सिक्योर कम्युनिकेशन जिस का इसी का
एक सक्सेसर है आपका टीएलएस ट्रांसपोर्ट
लेयर सिक्योरिटी। ठीक है? जो एसएसएल के
बाद यहां पे इंट्रोड्यूस की गई है। तो अब
जो है गाइस यहां पे इसको समझने की कोशिश
करते हैं।
ठीक है? तो यहां पे एचटीटीपीएस जब एचटीटीp
में डाउनग्रेड होता है तो वो एस जो है वो
खत्म हो जाती है। सिर्फ hटीtp बच जाता है
जो कि एक प्लेन टेक्स्ट प्रोटोकॉल है जहां
पे जो कि एक नॉन इंक्रिप्टेड प्रोटोकॉल
है। एचटीपीएस इज़ एन इंक्रिप्टेड प्रोटोकॉल
और एचटीdटीp इज़ नॉन इंक्रिप्टेड
प्रोटोकॉल। तो एसटीडीपीएस में जो
कम्युनिकेशन होती है क्लाइंट और सर्वर के
बीच में यूजर और सर्वर के बीच में एक
कंप्यूटर से दूसरे कंप्यूटर के बीच में एक
नेटवर्क से दूसरे नेटवर्क के बीच में वहां
पे जो कम्युनिकेशन होती है वो इंक्रिप्टेड
होता है। उसकी डेटा अगर कोई हटाकर चुरा भी
लेता है तो उसको पढ़ने के लिए उसको उसे
डिक्रिप्ट करना पड़ेगा। जो कि एक अलग केस
है, एक अलग कॉम्प्लेक्सिटी है। एंड अगर
इंक्रिप्शन तगड़ी हुई तो उसको डिक्रिप्ट
करने में काफी टाइम लग सकता है। एंड नियर
टू इंपॉसिबल भी पॉसिबल हो सकता है या
सालों लग सकते हैं। बट एचटीटीपी के केस
में जब कम्युनिकेशन होती है तो देयर
कम्युनिकेशन आर इन प्लेन टेक्स्ट्स। मतलब
यूजर इज़ यूजर नेम इज़ इक्वल टू डिफ़्रॉनिक्स
है तो यूजरनेम डिफ़्रॉनिक्स दिखेगा।
पासवर्ड 1 2 3 4 5 है तो पासवर्ड 1 2 3 4
5 ही दिखेगा। दिस इज़ व्हाट हैपेंस इन दैट
पर्टिकुलर केसेस। तो एसएसएल स्ट्रिपिंग
कांसेप्ट का सिंपल सा फंडा है कि
एचटीडीपीएस को एचटीडीपी पे डाउनग्रेड कर
दो और फिर कैप्चर कर लो। तो प्लेन टेक्स्ट
में कैप्चर होगा। क्योंकि अब इंक्रिप्टेड
को डिक्रिप्ट करना इतना आसान तो नहीं है
लेकिन इंक्रिप्शन को डिक्रिप्शन में
कन्वर्ट करके तो उसको देख सकते हैं। दिस
इज़ व्हाट एचटीडीपी एस टू एसटीडीपी मींस
एसएसएल स्ट्रिपिंग में ऐसा ही होता है। बस
सिंपल सा फंडा है। जैसे कोई अगर आप कोई
फैमिली में कोई एक बंदा किसी
बड़े
करप्शन के अगेंस्ट या किसी चीज के अगेंस्ट
खड़ा हो जाता है। मान लो कोई एक बंदा तो
उसको बहुत सारी ताकतें झुकाने की कोशिश
करती है।
राइट? और वो फिर भी ना झुके तो क्या उसका
क्या तरीका है? तरीका ये है या तो उसी को
हटा दो। तो एसटीपीएस को हटाना तो इंपॉसिबल
है ना। कोई अटैकर इस प्रोटोकॉल को कैसे
हटा देगा? तो दूसरा तरीका क्या है? उसके
घर के किसी और पे प्रेशर बनाओ। उसको बेंड
कर दो। उसको मजबूर कर दो और उसको वनरेबल
बना दो। वही काम यहां पर किया जाता है।
इसको बेंड करके वनरेबल बना के सीडीपी में
कन्वर्ट कर दिया जाता है ताकि अटैकर का
पर्सपेक्टिव फुलफिल हो जाए। उसके बाद एक
और टाइप है सेशन हाईजैकिंग।
दिस इज़ आल्सो अ वेरी नॉर्मल एंड गुड
कांसेप्ट। अटैकर स्टील सेशन कुकीज़ एंड
लॉग्स इन विदाउट पास।
कई बार आपने न्यूज़ में सुने होंगे। कई बार
बड़े-बड़े अ
यूर्स के चैनल हैक हो गए। चैनल का एक्सेस
किसी और के पास चला गया। उस पे अलग-अलग
कंटेंट्स चलने लगे। ईलॉन मस्क के वीडियोस
चलने लगे। क्रिप्टो करेंसी रिलेटेड
वीडियोस चलने लगे। बड़े-बड़े यूटर्स जिनके
मिलियंस में फॉलोवर्स हैं। आप सब जानते
हैं उन सबको। उन सबके अकाउंट हैक हुए हैं।
थोड़े बहुत लालच के चक्कर में या यू कैन
से कि एक एक प्रॉमिनेंट लालच ग्रीड जहां
पे इतना आपको ऐसा ऑफर किया जा रहा है जो
आप जल्दी रिजेक्ट नहीं कर सकते हैं। एक
वीडियो को जैसे अगर एक वीडियो को प्रमोट
करने में उनको ₹-25,000 मिल रहे हैं तो
किसी ने आके बोला कि ₹1 लाख देंगे तो यह
प्रॉमिनेंट थोड़ा सा एक अप्रोच हो गया
जिसमें कि उसको रिजेक्ट करना बहुत मुश्किल
हो जाता है किसी भी कंटेंट क्रिएटर के
लिए। तो हां हां ठीक है। ठीक है। अब वो
नहीं देख रहा कि क्या करवा रहा है वो
हमसे। वो हमसे एक पीडीएफ डाउनलोड करवा के
ओपन करवा ले रहा है। वो हमसे एक जिप फाइल
ओपन करवा ले रहा है। वो हमसे एक
एग्जीक्यूटेबल इंस्टॉल करवा ले रहा है या
ओपन करवा दे रहा है। और बैकग्राउंड में एक
बैकडोर इंस्टॉल कर दे रहा है। वो बैकडोर
या वो पर्टिकुलर जो मैलवेयर है वो स्टेशन
कुकीज़ को चुरा ले रही है। उनके ब्राउज़र के
अंदर जो प्रेजेंट है जो उस पर्टिकुलर
वेबसाइट से कनेक्टेड है एंड उनका ऑलरेडी
YouTube, Google अकाउंट लॉगिन होता है।
उनका एक्सेस डायरेक्ट ले लेते हैं वो
अटैकर। एंड अटैकर जब एक्सेस ले लेते हैं
तो उनको लॉगिन करने की भी जरूरत नहीं
होती। जब सशन कुकीज़ से वो अटैकर जब एक्सेस
लेते हैं तो जैसा Google वहां ओपन है वैसे
ही Google ओपन हो जाता है। अकाउंट के अंदर
अटैकर होता है और वो सारे काम कर सकता है
अकाउंट के अंदर जो वो बंदा और जो ओरिजिनल
ओनर उसका कर सकता है। तो अपने आप को
YouTube का मैनेजर वहां पे अपॉइंट कर
दिया। मैनेजर का मतलब है कि YouTube का
अपना एडमिन अपॉइंट कर दिया और YouTube का
चैनल कंट्रोल में ले लिया। उसको हटा भी
दिया। कई केसेस में तो ओटीपी ओटीपी का
झंझट अगर नहीं है तो तो ये था सेशन इसको
हम बोलते हैं सेशन हाईजैकिंग भैया ठीक
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] है हटकर स्टील
सेशन कुकीज़ एंड लॉग सीन विदाउट पासवर्ड
बिना पासवर्ड के लॉग इन कर लेता है
क्योंकि जरूरत नहीं पड़ती है सेशन कुकीज़ आ
गई तो उसमें लॉग इन क्रेडेंशियल्स भी होते
हैं एंड यू डोंट नीड टू एक्चुअली इन मेनी
केसेस कई केसेस में होता है इवन देखो
इनकम ऑथेंटिकेशन कुकीज़ बेसिकली आप बोल
सकते हैं अब मैं पे कुकीज़ के अंदर नहीं जा
रहा डीप क्योंकि यह इस इसका अभी कोई इसकी
कोई रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं है। बट स्टिल
मैंने आपको बोला कि मेरे मुंह से जितने भी
शब्द निकल रहे हैं, टर्म्स निकल रहे हैं
या कोई भी पॉइंट निकल रहा है तो आई वुड
रिक्वेस्ट एवरीबॉडी टू प्लीज गो थ्रू दैट
एक्सप्लोर वंस दोज़ टॉपिक्स एंड उसको
एक्सप्लोर करके उसके बारे में थोड़ा पढ़िए।
तो सेशन कुकीज़ में जब ऑथेंटिकेशन वाली
कुकीज़ की बात हम करें तो अगर उस तरह की
कुकीज़ कैप्चर कर ली जाती है तो वहां पे
लॉगिन आप आराम से जो है बिना पासवर्ड के
कर सकते हैं किसी भी एप्लीकेशन में। इवन
Netflix के केस में भी अगर मैं बात करूं
तो ये चीज़ पॉसिबल है क्योंकि वो लॉन्ग
लास्टिक एक कुकीज़ होती है जहां पे
एक्सपायरी इतनी जल्दी जब तक कि अंटिल
अनलेस कि लॉग आउट ना करें। वो नहीं होती
है उनके कुकीज़ एक्सपायर। तो उन कुकीज़ को
दूसरे यूजर के कुकीज़ को भी आप चुरा के
इंजेक्ट करके आप अपने सिस्टम में वो
Netflix अकाउंट लॉग इन कर सकते हैं। सेम
सेम गोज़ फॉर अ लॉट ऑफ वेब एप्लीकेशनेशंस।
बहुत सारे वेब एप्लीकेशन बहुत स्ट्रिक्ट
होते हैं। बैंकिंग एप्लीकेशनेशंस वगैरह तो
कुछ ज्यादा स्ट्रिक्ट होती है। उन सब में
ये सब काम नहीं करता। बट स्टिल मेनी
एप्लीकेशनेशंस आर वनरेबल टू दिस थिंग्स।
कई इंटेंशनल होते हैं, कई नॉन इंटेंशनल
होते हैं। अब यहां पे एग्जांपल क्या है?
यूजर लॉग्स इंटू वेबसाइट। अटैकर स्टील्स,
कुकीज़, अटैकर गस एक्सेस। सिंपल। यूजर
वेबसाइट में लॉगिन करता है। हटाकर किसी भी
तरीके से वह कुकीज़ जो होते हैं ऑथेंटिकेशन
वाले उसको चुरा लेता है और उसका एक्सेस
उसको मिल जाता है। इसी को हम सेशन
हाईजैकिंग बोलते हैं। Facebook में भी यह
बहुत सालों पहले बहुत इजी तरीके से होता
था क्योंकि Facebook के भी जो कुकीज़ होते
थे वो इसी तरीके से एक्सपायर ऐसे नहीं
होते थे। एंड उनकी कुकीज़
ईजीली एक्सपोर्ट होके एंड कोई भी उसको
चुरा सकता था। ऐसा होता था पहले जब मैं
कॉलेज के टाइम में था। बाद में Facebook
ने उस पे अपनी एडिशनल सिक्योरिटीज एंड सब
चीजें लगाई। एंड आज के टाइम में इट्स इट्स
अ वेरी टफ थिंग।
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़] नाउ
यहां पे ये आपको सेशन हजकिंग समझ में आ
गया होगा। आर यू गेटिंग गाइस? समझ में आया
सभी को? एक बार मुझे बता दीजिए। प्लीज लेट
मी नो।
ओके
चलो तो काफी लोगों को या समझ में आ गया हम
ऑफकोर्स क्या बात है अच्छा ये बताओ मतलब
क्लियर क्लियर होते चल रहा है ना आपका ये
जो टॉपिक्स से क्लियर होना है ये टॉपिक्स
बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट है आगे के लिए याद रखिएगा
ये चीज और लाइक ठोकते जाइए आप लोग जितने
जितने लोग हैं लाइक ठोक देना भाई। अ
ताकि पता चले कि लाइक करते हो आप कि नहीं
करते हो। समझ में तो आता है ना बिल्कुल आप
लोगों को जो चीजें मैं बता रहा हूं। ये
टॉपिक्स काफीेंट है गाइस। एंड दीज़ आर वेरी
वेरी रियली रियली वेरीेंट। आपको बाद में
इसकी अहमियत पता चलेगी
शायद।
तो आप समझ पाएंगे।
चलिए [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] ओके वेरी
गुड ओके सो नाउ लेट्स स्टार्ट एंड लेट्स
गो टू द अ नेक्स्ट पार्ट ऑफ एमआईटीएम
टाइप्स ऑफ़ एमआईडीएम दिस इज़ कॉल्ड एिल
ट्विन अटैक। इसके बारे में ऑलरेडी हम पढ़
चुके हैं, जान चुके हैं एविल ट्वीन के
बारे में पहले ही के क्लासेस में। तो मैं
इसको थोड़ा शॉर्ट में बता देता हूं। फेक
Wi-Fi नेटवर्क क्रिएट करना होता है। एविल
ट्विन का मतलब जिसमें कि यूज़र्स कनेक्ट
करते हैं अटैकर उन ट्रैफिक्स को इंटरसेप्ट
करते हैं। मतलब एक ऑलरेडी Wi-Fi नेटवर्क
चल रहा है। मान लो कि मेरा Wi-Fi नेटवर्क
चल रहा है। एंड एक मेरे ही Wi-Fi नेटवर्क
का सेम नेटवर्क नेम के साथ सेम एसएस आईडी
के साथ एक और फेक वाई-फाई का नेटवर्क एसएस
आईडी क्रिएट करना। वो भी पासवर्ड के बिना
पासवर्ड लेस। एंड उस जेन्युइन वाई-फाई
नेटवर्क जो पासवर्ड वाला था उससे यूज़र्स
को डिस्कनेक्ट कर देना। ऐसा ऐसा करना।
इससे क्या होगा? यह वाई-फाई अटैक्स जो
होते हैं, पेन टेस्टिंग जो होते हैं,
उसमें यह सब काम आराम से हो सकता है। इवन
विदाउट कनेक्टिंग टू दैट नेटवर्क यू कैन
डिस्कनेक्ट यूज़र्स फ्रॉम दैट पर्टिकुलर
नेटवर्क। ऐसा भी पॉसिबिलिटी है। और फिर आप
एक फ्री वाला Wi-Fi नेटवर्क चालू कर
दीजिए। तो यूज़र्स जो हैं वो उस फ्री वाले
से कनेक्ट हो जाते हैं। हमारे फोन के अंदर
मतलब ऐसी मैकेनिज्म भी है कि अगर कोई फ्री
और स्ट्रेंथ स्ट्रेंथफुल नेटवर्क दिखता है
तो ऑटोमेटिक कनेक्ट करने के लिए कोशिश की
जाती है आपके डिवाइस की तरफ से। तो वो
नेटवर्क कनेक्ट हो गया। जैसे ही कनेक्ट
हुआ भैया एक पेज लॉग इन ऑथेंटिकेशन पेज
खुलेगा तो उससे जो है आप डिफरेंट टाइप्स
ऑफ डिटेल्स शेयर कर सकते हैं अटैकर्स के
साथ एंड अटैकर आपके ट्रैफिक को कैप्चर कर
सकता है क्योंकि वो एक फेक नेटवर्क होता
है जो अटैकर कंट्रोलोल्ड होता है ना कि
आपका नॉर्मल इंटरनेट कनेक्शन होता है जो
नॉर्मल आपका वाई-फाई है। ठीक है? तो ये
होता है इविल टन अटैक। इसके बारे में पहले
ही हमने डिस्कस करी हुई थी। अब आते हैं
एमआईटीएम के रियल एसोसिएट सिनेरियो में कि
रियल एसोसिएट सिनेरियो के केस में क्या
एग्जैक्टली अलर्ट में आपको मिलता है? तो
जब आप अलर्ट की बात करते हैं तो मल्टीपल
यूज़र्स एक्सेसिंग सेम गेटवे आईपी यह आपको
मिलेगा। अब मल्टीपल यूज़र्स जब सेम गेटवे
आईपी को एक्सेस कर रहे हैं यानी कि जो फेक
आईपी है भैया आपका तो वहां पे एक अलर्ट
आता है। एंड वहां पे थोड़ी सी समझदारी
वाली बात होनी चाहिए। समझ में आनी चाहिए।
एज एन एस एसओसीएल वन एनालिस्ट एसएसएल
सर्टिफिकेट मिसमैच क्योंकि अह आपने एसएसएल
के साथ छेड़छाड़ कर दी है डाउनग्रेड एंड
ऑल कर दिया तो सर्टिफिकेट मिसमैच होने के
चांसेस सर्टिफिकेट एरर होने के चांसेस एंड
वार्निंग वो आ सकते हैं तो उसको अलर्ट में
वो आ सकती है आपके सस्िशियस डीएनएस
रिस्पों्ससेस डीएनएस जो है वह सस्िशियस
रिस्पांस आपको देगा लाइक क्योंकि डीएनएस
पोइजनिंग हुई है गलत आईपी पे मैपिंग हो
रही है तो आपको सस्िशियस डीएनएस रिस्पांस
में भी देखने को मिल सकता है दिस कुड बी
हैपनिंग इन्वेस्टिगेशन में क्या कर सकते
हैं आप एआरपी टेबल को चेक कर सकते हैं कि
भैया सारे आईपी और मैक सही बैठे तो हैं
कोई फर्जी तो नहीं बैठ गया आके उस टेबल के
अंदर डीएनएस log में कि भैया सही से सारी
डोमेनस सही आईपीस पे तो मैप हो रही है ना
ऐसा तो नहीं कि कोई डोमेन googlecom अपने
IP पे ना हो किसी और ही आईपी पे मैप हो
रही है और उस IP उस आईपी का ओनर कोई और ही
है अटैकर कंट्रोल IP है एंड चेक नेटवर्क
ट्रैफिक एनमलीज़ अब नेटवर्क ट्रैफिक एनमलीज़
नेटवर्क ट्रैफिक में कुछ गड़बड़ तो नहीं आ
रही है। कोई गेस्ट आईपी तो नहीं आपको दिख
रहा है। कोई ऐसा मलिशियस आईपी तो शो नहीं
हो रहा है जो इधर से उधर कर रहा है। यह सब
चीज़ आपको देखनी है। ठीक है? ये हो गया
एमआईटीएम का रियल एसोसिएट सिनेरियो की
मैंने बात आपको बताई है। अब इसके
प्रिवेंशन की बात करें तो यहां पे काउंटर
मेजर आपको थोड़ी बहुत जानकारी होनी चाहिए
क्योंकि काउंटर मेजर आपको पता होगा तो इट
विल बी मोर बेनिफिशियल फॉर यू। एचटीडीपीएस
का यूज़ करना टीएलएस इंक्रिप्शन। ऑब्वियस
सी बात है। मैंने बोला था एसएसएल इज़ द प्र
एसएसएल का एसएसएल का सक्सेसर आ चुका है
टीएलएस तो उसका यूज़ करना। वीपीए का यूज़
करना। वीpए इज़ अ वेरी वेरीेंट
थिंग इन साइबर सिक्योरिटी। देखो वीपीएंस
एक ऐसी चीज है जो आपके और मेन सर्वर के
बीच में बैठे रहते हैं और आपकी ट्रांसमिशन
में हेल्प करते हैं। इसके फायदे बहुत सारे
हैं। यह मैन इन द मिडिल को भी रोकने में
हेल्प करता है। कर सकता है। वीपीएंस जो है
वो अगर आप यूज़ करते हैं तो एक तो
सिक्योरिटी आपकी आइडेंटिटी थप्ट होने के
चांसेस बचते हैं। आपकी प्राइवेसी जो है वो
बनी रहती है। आपकी अ जो हां अ आइडेंटिटी
डिस्क्लोज़र जो आप नहीं चाहते हैं वो आपकी
नहीं हो पाती है। एंड यह सब चीजें सही है
अंटिल अनलेस कि वह वीpए ही आपकी लॉग्स
इधर-उधर ना सेल करने लगे, बांटने लगे,
शेयर करने लगे तब तक तो ठीक है। अब आपको
ट्रस्ट कैसे होगा वीpए के ऊपर में? तो कोई
किसी पे आप Google पे ट्रस्ट करते हैं? आप
बताइए मुझे आप। बहुत लोग क्वेश्चन करते
हैं सर हम वीpए पे कैसे ट्रस्ट करें?
हमारे तो डाटा सेल कर सकते हैं। हमारे
डेटा को दे सकते हैं। भैया ये तो वीpएन
है। छोटी सी चीज है जो तुम कभी-कभी यूज़
करोगे। डेली जो फोन में Google के
एप्लीकेशनेशंस और Google को यूज कर रहे हो
उस पे क्या ट्रस्ट है तुम्हारा? तुमको उस
पे 100% ट्रस्ट है। अब मैं बोलता हूं कि
वो 100% ट्रस्ट एक दिन पता चले कि कोई काम
का नहीं था। आपके डाटा फिर भी इधर-उधर सेल
हो रहे हैं। सब कुछ इवन आप किसी से कोई
टॉपिक पे बात करो यार उसके एड्स आने लगते
हैं। यह कोई बात हो गई यार। कौन सी डाटा
है? क्या है यार? क्या हो क्या रहा है
एक्सैक्टली? व्हाट इज़ हैपनिंग एक्सैक्टली
अराउंड यू? यू आर बीइंग मॉनिटर्ड
इनडायरेक्टली। यू आर बीइंग मॉनिटर्ड फ्रॉम
एवरीवेयर इनडायरेक्टली। बोला नहीं जा रहा
है। बस आपको बताया नहीं जा रहा है तो आप
खुश हैं। सिंपल सा फंडा है। मतलब अगर मैं
मैं गरीब हूं तो मैं फील नहीं कर रहा हूं
तो ठीक है। बट जब तक कि मुझे कोई आके
बोलना 10 बार ना बोले भाई तू गरीब है। भाई
तू गरीब है। भाई तू गरीब है। तब मुझे
फीलिंग आने लगी कि अरे हां यार लग रहा है
मैं गरीब ही हूं। और अदरवाइज मैं बैठा हूं
ऐसे ही है। मैं मेरी यही यही दुनिया तब तक
मुझे क्या लग रहा है? मेरी तो यही दुनिया
यही तो सबसे बड़ी दुनिया है। खतरनाक
दुनिया है। जैसे कि एक जैसे कि एक कहावत
है ना कि वह मेंढक जो होता है मेंढक कुएं
में उसको लगता है कि यह कुआं ही सब कुछ
है। कुआं ही लगता है कि पूरी दुनिया है।
इससे बड़ा तो कुछ हो ही नहीं सकता है।
अंटिल अनलेस कि वो जब तक कुएं से बाहर
नहीं आ जाता कुदक के फुदक के। जब वो बाहर
आता है तो उसका दिमाग चकरा जाता है। अरे
ये क्या हो रहा है भाई? तो हम Google वगल
यूज़ कर रहे हैं। जब तक हम सिक्योर सेफ
बैठे हुए हैं। चुपचाप बैठे हैं। हमारे साथ
कुछ खास कुछ बुरा नहीं हो रहा है। कुछ खास
हमारे ऊपर इंपैक्ट नहीं पड़ रहा है। तब तक
हमें सब सेफ एंड सिक्योर लग रहा है। एक
दिन किसी दिन कुछ ऐसा हो जाएगा बड़ा कांड
जब हर एक पर्सन को इंपैक्ट कर देगा। हर एक
मोबाइल होल्डर, हर एक Google ओनर, हर एक
Google अकाउंट होल्डर या हर एक Google
सर्विस यूजर को वो इंपैक्ट कर देगा। उस
दिन सबको समझ में आ जाएगा कि अभी तक भैया
सब यह सब एक छलावा था।
सब [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] एक छला हुआ
था। तो इतना क्यों टेंशन लेना है कि वीpए
यूज़ क्या करेंगे? है ना? सही बोला ना? समझ
में तो आ ही रहा होगा। सिंपल सा फंडा है।
कितने लोग एग्री करते हैं इस चीज से। पता
नहीं कितने लोग करते हैं। बट मैं तो 100%
एग्री करता हूं। तो ये वीपीए क्या देगा?
डाटा छोड़ दो। अभी करंट में तुम्हारा
हेल्प कर रहा है। तुम्हारे को सिक्योर
तुम्हारी प्राइवेसी को मेंटेन कर रहा है।
उससे मतलब रखो। तुम इललीगल काम थोड़ी ना
करने जा रहे हो। इललीगल करोगे तो डरो। फिर
तो वीpए यूज़ करके भी तुम बच नहीं सकते।
राइट? सिक्योर डीएनएस। दिस इज़ द कॉनंसेप्ट
डीएनएस सेक डीएनएस सिक्योरिटी। जहां पे
डीएनएस
को और भी ज्यादा सिक्योर किया जाता है।
डीएनएस अह के अंदर में जो कम्युनिकेशन
होती है, हरार्की होती है, उसको सिक्योर
किया जाता है। तो, यह भी एक अच्छा
इंपॉर्टेंट अपडेट स्टेप है। हालांकि अगेन
मैं आपको बोलूंगा डीएनएस के बारे में
थोड़ा पढ़िए। वीpए क्या होता है, उसके
बारे में थोड़ा पढ़िए। एचटीपीएस एचटीपी के
बारे में थोड़ा पढ़िए। एसएसएल टीएसएल
टीएलएस के बारे में थोड़ा सा पढ़िए। एआरपी
एआरपी टेबल्स के बारे में पढ़िए। डीएनएस
डीएनएस कैश के बारे में पढ़िए। ये सब
चीजें पढ़िए थोड़ी एक्सप्लोर कीजिए
हल्की-हल्की। बहुत नहीं पढ़ना है डीप में
बट ओ अ बिट ऑफ अ एक्सप्लोरेशन शुड बी
देयर। राइट?
ओके। [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] अब आते हैं
अब आते हैं डिस्ट्रीब्यूटेड डिनाइयल ऑफ
सर्विस। राइट? डिस्ट्रीब्यूटेड डिनाइल ऑफ
सर्विस। ठीक? अब डिस्ट्रीब्यूटेड डिनाइल
ऑफ सर्विस क्या होता है? पहले हम इसको
समझते हैं। जस्ट अ सेकंड।
ये कहां गया?
पहले मैं इसको थोड़ा सा ठीक कर देता हूं।
[संगीत]
लेट मी करेक्ट इट फर्स्ट।
हम हम हम
ये मेरा सेम मैन इन द मिडिल रह गया था
शायद तो इसको करेक्ट करना बहुत जरूरी है।
ऑलराइट [गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
ओके आपको जो मिलेगा पीडीएफ या जो भी है वो
आपको करेक्टेड ही मिलेगा। तो उसके लिए
बेफिक्र रहिए आप।
[खांसने की आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
मैंने जोश जोश-जोश में चेंज नहीं किया
होगा। बट कोई बात नहीं है। चलिए। सो लेट्स
लेट्स गो विद द डिस्ट्रीब्यूटेड डिनाइल ऑफ़
सर्विस।
ओके।
डीडीओएस
हालांकि डॉस भी एक कांसेप्ट है डिनाइलो
सर्विस एंड देयर इज़ अ कॉनंसेप्ट
डिस्ट्रीब्यूटेड डिनाइलो सर्विस
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
डॉस जहां पे एक अटैकर
एक सर्वर पे अटैक कर रहा होता है। बहुत
सारे पैकेट्स भेज रहा होता है। डीडीओएस
जहां पे एक अटैकर बहुत सारे
कॉम्प्रोमाइज्ड कंप्यूटर का यूज करके उनको
एज अ बॉट यूज करके और एक साथ उनका यूज
करके अटैक कर रहा होता है कंप्यूटर पे। सो
दिस इज़ द मोस्ट डेंजरस अटैक। यह एक ऐसा
अटैक है जो पास्ट में बड़ी-बड़ी वेब
सर्वर्स बाय द बिग कंपनीज लाइक Facebook,
Google, Instagram, Microsoft,
Twitter व्हाटएवर देयर आर द बिग नेम्स यू
नो दे ऑल आर बीइंग हिट बाय दिस पर्टिकुलर
अटैक। डीडीओएस। बाकी अटैक्स भले उनका कुछ
नहीं कर सकते हैं या नहीं कर पाते। बट यह
जो अटैक है डीडीओएस, दिस हैज़ नो क्योर।
इसका कोई इलाज नहीं है। सीधा-सीधा मैं
आपको बताता हूं। इसका कोई इलाज नहीं है।
एक सोशल इंजीनियरिंग का कोई इलाज नहीं है।
एक डीडीओएस का कोई इलाज नहीं है। इससे
बचने का तरीका बस इतना है कि आप अपने
कैपेसिटी को आप अपने सर्वर की अ
आप अपने जो सर्वर की बेसिकली
स्पेसिफिकेशंस एंड उसकी जो वर्किंग या
उसकी जो कैपेसिटी है उसको इस तरीके से
रखिए कि उसको कोई डाउनग्रेड ना कर पाए।
मतलब उसको कोई डाउन ना कर पाए। इसका यही
तरीका और कोई भी इसका बचने का तरीका
अप्रोच नहीं है। सिंप सिंपल सा फंडा है।
तो डीडीओएस का मतलब होता है
डिस्ट्रीब्यूटेड डिनर सर्विस। DS का मतलब
होता है डिनाइल ऑफ़ सर्विस। एक ऐसा टैग
जहां पे सर्वर अपनी सर्विस देने से मना कर
दे। मतलब मैं एज अ क्लाइंट हूं। मैं एज अ
यूजर हूं। मैंने बोला Google.com लॉग इन
खोल के दो मुझे। अब Google का सर्वर बोलता
है नहीं दूंगा। क्यों? क्योंकि मैं लायक
क्यों नहीं हूं? मैं आई एम नॉट एबल टू
प्रोवाइड यू द सर्विस। मेरे ऊपर दिक्कत हो
रही है यार। मैं इतने सर्विसेस इतने
रिक्वेस्ट को हैंडल ही नहीं कर पा रहा।
क्यों? क्योंकि अटैकर ने ऐसे इतनी-इतनी
रिक्वेस्ट मेरे पास भेज दिए कि आई कैन नॉट
हैंडल दोज़ रिक्वेस्टेस। तो मैं आपको भी एक
लेजिटमेट यूजर होते हुए भी आपको मैं आपको
आपका रिसोंड नहीं करूंगा क्योंकि मैं अब
उस लायक नहीं बचा। मैं उस लायक नहीं रहा।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] सो उसी को जब
डिस्ट्रीब्यूटेड तरीके से किया जाए बहुत
सारे कंप्यूटरटर्स बॉट्स को एक साथ मार
दिया जाए कंप्यूटर पे एक सर्वर पे एक कम
एक नेटवर्क डिवाइस पे तो उसको डीडीओएस
कहते हैं। व्हाट इज डीडीओए? अ डीडीओस अटैक
फ्लड्स अ सिस्टम विथ मैसिव ट्रैफिक। मैसिव
ट्रैफिक टेराबाइट्स पर सेकंड के स्पीड में
एक सेकंड में टेराबाइट्स ऑफ डाटा पैकेट्स
अटैक किया जा रहा है। पेटाबाइट्स ऑफ डेटा
पैकेट्स को अटैक किया जा रहा है। एक सेकंड
में एक पेटाबाइट 100 पेटाबाइट 10 पेटाबाइट
के पैकेट्स को छोड़ा जा रहा है एक सर्वर
पे जिसकी उतनी कैपेसिटी नहीं है। बात यहां
पे सिंपल सा लॉजिक है। समझ लीजिए। आप एक
वेबसाइट चलाते हैं या आपने देखा होगा कई
छोटे-मोटे वेबसाइट्स होते हैं या नॉर्मल
बड़े भी वेबसाइट अगर होते हैं। लेट्स
लेट्स अस्यूम इट। मैं यहां पे एक बहुत
अच्छे वेबसाइट के एग्जांपल लेने वाला हूं
जिससे आप भी आपको भी पता है। आईआरसीटीc की
वेबसाइट आपको पता है। सबको पता है या किसी
भी एग्जाम पोर्टल जहां पे रिजल्ट आने वाला
होता है। चाहे वो स्टेट बोर्ड्स के
वेबसाइट्स हो चाहे वो सीबीएसई के
वेबसाइट्स हो। जब 10थ 12th का बोर्ड का
रिजल्ट आने वाला होता है या स्टेट
एग्जामिनेशन के बोर्ड के रिजल्ट्स आने
वाले होते हैं या स्टेट बोर्ड्स के उस समय
जब आप वेबसाइट पे जाएंगे वेबसाइट क्रैश हो
जाती है। वेबसाइट गेट क्रैश वेबसाइट डोंट
वर्क इन द इंटेंडेंट वे एट दैट प्लेस एट
दैट टाइम वो एक डीडीएस अटैक ही होता है।
तो वहां पे एक नॉन इंटेंशनल अटैक होता है।
किसी इंटेंसिटी के साथ नहीं होती है। यहां
अटैकर एक इंटेंसिटी के साथ अटैक करता है।
आईआरसीटीc वेबसाइट्स
10:00 बजे सुबह और 11:00 बजे आप ओपन करके
देखिए अगर आपका ओपन हो के लॉग इन आप लॉग
इन बस आपको कुछ नहीं करना टिकट बुक नहीं
करने आप बस 10:00 बजे एग्जैक्ट शार्प 10
पे आप iआरसीटीc की वेबसाइट को ओपन करके
अपने अकाउंट को लॉगिन करके थोड़ी ट्रेन
सर्च करके देख लीजिए कुछ नहीं हो पाएगा कम
से कम 1 2 मिनट तक तो नहीं होगा क्योंकि
उस 1 2 मिनट पे पीक ट्रैफिक जो होती है उस
वेबसाइट पे होती है और उस वेबसाइट की
कैपेसिटी नहीं है उस सर्वर की उतनी
ट्रैफिक को एक्सेप्ट और उस ट्रैफिक को
झेलने की तो वह अपनी सर्विस देना बंद कर
देता है। अब कितनी भी बड़ी सर्वर कितना भी
एडवांस सर्वर आपने अभी सेटअप कर लिया या
कुछ भी व्हाटएवर मैं यहां पे क्वांटम
कंप्यूटिंग की बात नहीं कर रहा। क्वांटम
थ्योरी की बात नहीं कर रहा। मैं यहां पे
अभी तक की अभी की कंप्यूटिंग की बात कर
रहा हूं। नाउ आई मैं आई एम टॉकिंग अबाउट
सुपर कंप्यूटरटर्स। आई एम टॉकिंग अबाउट
जनरिक कंप्यूटरटर्स। तो आप सर्वर जेनेरिक
सर्वर्स रखे हो भैया तो उसकी कैपेसिटी
होती है। उसका एक लोड लोड लेने का
कैपेसिटी होता है। अब उस लोड से ज्यादा
लोड दोगे तो सर्वर क्रैश तो करेगा ही।
सर्वर अपना काम करना बंद कर देगा। सर्वर
अपनी सर्विस देना बंद कर देगा।
सिंपल
जैसे रोड पे जाम लगती है। हाईवेज पे जाम
लगती है। आगे जाम लगा कहीं पे। पीछे से
धीरे-धीरे जाम लगनी शुरू हो जाती है। और
जाम का एक क्यू बन जाता है। एक बफर बन
जाता है। बफर लॉक बन जाता है। राइट? तो अब
वो जाम पूरी तरीके से पूरी तरीके से ऐसी
हो जाती है कि कोई दूसरा बंदा आसपास से
पास भी नहीं हो पाता। सेम गोज़ फॉर दिस
कांसेप्ट। एक सर्वर पे इतने सारे ट्रैफिक
भेज दिए जाते हैं कि जब नॉर्मल कोई यूजर
उस ट्रैफिक में घुसने की कोशिश करता है तो
घुस ही नहीं पाता है। क्योंकि ऑलरेडी
ट्रैफिक पूरा कंजेस्टेड हो चुका है।
ऑलरेडी इतने सारे रिक्वेस्ट उस पे जा चुके
हैं कि अब वो उस उस यूजर का रिक्वेस्ट
वहां तक पहुंच ही नहीं पा रहा है। सर्वर
रिस्पॉन्ड ही नहीं कर पा रहा। सर्वर बोल
रहा है भाई अब ना हो पाएगा।
बस सिंपल सा फंडा है। तो इसको हम बोलते
हैं डिस्ट्रीब्यूटेड इन सर्विस। आर यू
गेटिंग दिस कांसेप्ट? समझ में आ रहा है आप
लोगों को? बताइए। आर यू गेटिंग
डिस्ट्रीब्यूटेड इन सर्विस डीडीओएस का। और
यह क्यों किया जाता है? एक सिस्टम, एक
सर्वर, एक कंप्यूटर, एक एक वेबसाइट, एक
वेब एप्लीकेशन को स्लो करने के लिए,
अनरिस्पांसिव करने के लिए और कंप्लीटली
डाउन करने के लिए। यह इसका मेन मोटिव है।
आर यू गेटिंग गाइस? प्लीज बताइए।
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़][अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
प्लीज मुझे बताइए सभी लोग। एवरीवन प्लीज
लेट मी नो। सभी लोग आंसर करेंगे तभी मैं
आगे बढूंगा क्योंकि आप लोग में से कई लोग
मतलब बहुत कम लोग आंसर करते हैं।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ठीक है।
ठीक है। ठीक है। चलिए अच्छी बात है। कई
काफी लोगों ने आंसर किया। समझ में आ रहा
है। इट्स क्लियर। क्लियर क्लियर बहुत
बढ़िया।
अच्छी बात है।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
बहुत अच्छे से समझ में आ रहा है। गुड।
बढ़िया।
तो यह हमारा डिस्ट्रीब्यूटेड सर्विस था।
अब इसके गोल्स क्या होते हैं? पहले उसको
समझते हैं। वेबसाइट्स को ऑफलाइन लेकर जाना
इसका प्राइमरी गोल है। बिनेस ऑपरेशंस को
डिस्टरब कर देना। क्योंकि अगर कोई वेबसाइट
कोई वेबसाइट ऐसी है, कोई ऐसा बिज़नेस है जो
अपनी वेबसाइट पे ही डिपेंड करती है। मान
के चलो ना। बहुत सारी होते हैं। Facebook
का वेबसाइट ही डाउन हो जाए 2 घंटे के लिए
Facebook को मिलियंस ऑफ बिलियंस ऑफ डॉलर्स
का नुकसान हो जाएगा। क्योंकि सारा बिजनेस
उस पे चल रहा है ना। है ना? अब मेक माय
ट्रिप को कोई एक घंटे तक डाउन कर दे तो
पूरी MMY ट्रिप के कंपनी के रेवेन्यू पर
फर्क पड़ जाएगा। राइट? शादी.com को डाउन
कर दे कोई उनका बहुत बड़ा बिजनेस लॉस हो
जाएगा। राइट?
तो कई ऐसे बिजनेसेस हैं जो प्रॉपर अपने
वेब एप्लीकेशन या अपने वेबसाइट्स पर ही
डिपेंड होते हैं, डिपेंडेंट हैं। एंड इफ
देयर इज़ डीडीओएस देयर आर केओस देयर आर
लार्ज नंबर ऑफ इंपैक्ट ऑन द रेवेन्यू ऑफ़
दोज़ पर्टिकुलर बिज़नेस।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] सो वेबसाइट
को ऑफलाइन ले जाना, बिज़नेस ऑपरेशंस को
डिस्ट्रप्ट कर देना, एक्सटॉर्शन मतलब कि
पैसे दो। अदरवाइज़ हम तो यह काम करते
रहेंगे। हम तो अटैक करते रहेंगे। तुम्हारा
बिज़नेस खराब करते रहेंगे। पैसा चाहिए। अब
तुम्हें तुम्हारे बिज़नेस में हम अटैक तब
तक करते रहेंगे जब तक कि तुम हमें ₹00 ना
दे दो। छोटा अमाउंट है। छोटा मांगा छोटा
अटैकर था। बड़ा अटैकर होगा तो पता नहीं 5
लाख भी मांग ले 50 लाख भी मांग ले। डिपेंड
करता है बिज़नेस कैसा। अब बिज़नेस की
रेवेन्यू ही 1 लाख हो तो 500 तो बहुत बड़ी
बात हो गई। तो या तो 50 लाख मांग लो। अब
मान लो कि वो 500 पे कर दे बट उसका 5 लाख
का नुकसान हो रहा है। तो 500 पे करने में
कोई दिक्कत नहीं होती है कई बिज़नेसेस को।
एंड दे पे रैंसम हो गया वो रैंसम रैंसम
रैंसम डॉस अटैक डायवर्जन ऑफ़ अदर अटैक्स
उसके थ्रू अदर अटैक्स को डाइवर्ट करना उस
पे सिंपल तो ये मेन गोल है डीडीओएस का जो
मेन गोल होता है।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
अब यहां पे रियल एसओसी एग्जांपल मैं आपको
समझा देता हूं।
हां यहां पे एक क्वेश्चन है जगतगुरु
स्वामी
हैंडल से जो आते हैं उनका वेबसाइट की
कैपेसिटी कैसे चेक करें? देखो, वेबसाइट की
कैपेसिटी आपकी जो सर्वर आप जो लेते हैं ना
जैसे आपने जहां से सर्वर लिया है खरीदते
हैं लोग सर्वर राइट होस्टिंगर से लिया है
या आपने ब्लू होस्ट से लिया है या आपने
gडी से लिया है। सर्वर लेते हैं उसी पे
होस्ट करते हैं वेबसाइट्स को। तो उस सर्वर
की जो कॉन्फ़िगरेशन होती है वही उसकी लोड
कैपेसिटी है। सर्वर्स एक कंप्यूटर ही होते
हैं जिनका अपना एसएसडी या हार्ड डिस्क
होता है, रैम होती है, अपना नेटवर्क
कंपोनेंट होता है, इनपुट आउटपुट सिस्टम्स
होते हैं। आई नोट सब कुछ होते हैं। तो
भैया जो रैम आपको मिली मान लो सर्वर के।
मान लो आप 4 GB रैम के साथ ऑपरेट कर रहे
हो। चार और कोई इतना ट्रैफिक भेज दे रहा
है जो 4 GB रैम को यूटिलाइज़ कर जा रहा है।
4 GB रैम हैंडल नहीं कर पा रही उसको तो
डाउन हो जाएगा। प्रोसेसर क्या है? कौन से?
कितने प्रोसेसर्स हैं? टू कोर्स हैं, फोर
कोर्स हैं? क्या है? उसके अकॉर्डिंग
सर्वर्स की लोड डिसाइड होती है। राइट?
चलिए [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] रियल
एसोस एग्जांपल हम समझते हैं। अलर्ट एक आता
है मान लो ट्रैफिक इंक्रीज फ्रॉम 2000
रिक्वेस्ट पर सेकंड टू 200k रिक्वेस्ट पर
सेकंड। मतलब 2000 से 2 लाख रिक्वेस्ट पर
सेकंड ट्रैफिक आ गया। ये अलर्ट है। सोर्स
क्या है? मल्टीपल कंट्रीज से आ रहे हैं।
ये एंड पॉइंट स्लैश लॉग इन लॉग इन वाला
एंड पॉइंट पे ये टारगेट किया जा रहा है।
तो ये क्या हो सकता है? एक एप्लीकेशन लेयर
डीडीओएस अटैक होता है जो कि वैलिड होता है
एनओएस प्रॉप के अकॉर्डिंग। मतलब आप जब
रिपोर्ट करेंगे एप्लीकेशन लेयर डीडीओस
अटैक तो दिस विल बी कंसीडर्ड। नॉर्मल
डीडीओस अटैक कंसीडर नहीं होता डॉस अटैक जो
आप नॉर्मली ऐसे करके डाउन करने का करते
हैं। बट एप्लीकेशन लेयर ऑफ़ एप्लीकेशन अ
डीडीएस अटैक जो होते हैं उसको काउंट किया
जाता है। कई कंपनीज़ करती है। तो इस तरह के
अलर्ट आएंगे। तो इसको लाइकली आप क्या
बोलेंगे? एप्लीकेशन लेयर या डीडीओएस अटैक
इसको आप बोलेंगे। अब आते हैं इसके भी टाइप
कुछ टाइप्स होते हैं। अब देखो डीडीओएस
अटैक के बहुत सारे टाइप्स होते हैं। एंड
हर एक टाइप का एक अलग डेफिनेशन है। एक अलग
उसका थ्यरी है एंड एक अलग डिटेल्ड वे में
आप उसको पढ़ सकते हैं लिटरली।
तो अगर आप एथिकल हैकिंग में काफी इंटरेस्ट
रखते हैं एंड इनको एक्सप्लोर करना चाहते
हैं उस पॉइंट ऑफ व्यू से तो बिल्कुल
कीजिए। कर सकते हैं। बट एसओसीएल वन के
पॉइंट ऑफ व्यू से बेसिक नॉलेज हल्कीफुल्की
नॉलेज बेसिक आपको इनके बारे में हो जाए।
दैट विल बी मोर दैन इनफ क्योंकि आपका काम
अटैक करना नहीं है। डिफेंड करना है।
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़][अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
सबसे पहले डीडीएस अटैक्स में आते हैं
वॉल्यूममेट्रिक अटैक्स एंड प्रोटोकॉल
अटैक्स। तो वॉल्यूममेट्रिक अटैक्स मतलब
क्या होता है? नेटवर्क के बैंडविथ को फ्लड
कर देना। इसके केस में यही होता है कि
नेटवर्क का जो बैंडविथ है उसको फ्लड कर
दो। कम्युनिकेशन ही नहीं हो पाएगी। कोई
ट्रांसमिशन ही नहीं हो पाएगी। मामला खत्म
है वहां पे। सिंपल। एग्जांपल क्या होते
हैं? यूडीपी फ्लड अटैक, आईसीएमपी फ्लड
अटैक, सीन फ्लड और पिंग ऑफ डेथ। ये आ जाते
हैं प्रोटोकॉल अटैक में। अब यहां पे दो
अटैक हो रहे हैं। यूडीपी एंड आईसीएमपी।
यहां पे आपके सीन एंड पिंग ऑफ डेथ हो रहा
है। तो ये वॉल्यूममेट्री वॉल्यूममेट्रिक
में आते हैं। ये प्रोटोकॉल में आते हैं।
इसका रीज़न क्या है कि यहां पे लार्ज नंबर
ऑफ
वॉल्यूम्स में अटैक होता है। जो नेटवर्क
के बैंडविथ को डिस्ट्रप्ट करने के लिए यूज़
में लिया जाता है। और यहां पे टारगेट
सर्वर के रिसोर्सेज को
टारगेट सर्वर के रिसोर्सेज जो होते हैं
उसको अटैक किया जाता है। जिसमें कि एक सन
फ्लड अटैक होता है। एक पिंग ऑफ़ डेथ होती
है। अब देखो यूडीपी फ्लड हो गया, आईसीएमपी
फ्लड हो गया। सो देयर आर सेवरल
कांसेप्ट्स। देयर आर सेवरल कांसेप्ट्स।
ठीक है? इसमें और भी जैसे
स्मरफ एक कांसेप्ट होता है। फ्रैगल एक
कांसेप्ट होता है। जहां पे एक में यूडीपी
का आईसीएमपी का यूज़ होता है। एक में
यूडीपी का यूज़ होता है। सो दीज़ आर डिटेल्ड
अह थिंग कांसेप्ट्स। यू डोंट हैव टू डील
विथ इट। कोई दिक्कत नहीं है। अगर आपको
नहीं भी पता है तो थोड़ी बहुत हल्कीफुल्की
इनके बारे में जान लेंगे कि यूडी फ्लड में
कि यूडीपी का यूज किया जाता है। एसएमपी
में आईसीएमपी का पैकेट्स का यूज़ किया
जाता है। सिन फ्लड में सिंक्रोनाइज पैकेज
का यूज़ किया जाता है। जो थ्री वे हैं एंड
में आप सिन पैकेट्स बेचते हैं उसका यूज़
किया जाता है। पिंग ऑफ डेथ में क्या हो
जाता है कि पिंग
मतलब कि
पिंग ऑफ डेथ अटैक एक तरह का ऐसा मान सकते
हैं कि एक ऐसी वैल्यू पिंग कर देना एक ऐसी
वैल्यू के साथ पैकेट्स को पिंग करना मतलब
पैकेट्स के थ्रू पिंग करना इतनी ज्यादा
अमाउंट में कि वहां पे उसकी रिस्पांस की
डेथ हो जाए एंड वहां पे सर्विस देना बंद
हो जाए। तो दीज़ आर द अटैक टाइप्स।
वॉल्यूममेट्रिक में नेटवर्क बैंडविथ को
अटैक किया जाता है। जिसके एग्जांपल है
यूडीपी फ्लड अटैक टाइप्स आईसीएमपी फ्लड
अटैक। प्रोटोकॉल अटैक्स में टारगेट सर्वर
के रिसोर्सेज जो होते हैं उनको यूटिलाइज़
किया जाता है। उस रिसोर्सेज को खत्म करने
की कोशिश की जाती है। जैसे कि एक पिंग ऑफ़
डेथ में क्या होगा कि कोई आप किसी वेबसाइट
को पिंग करते हैं तो वो क्या देता है?
रिस्पांस ही देता है। है ना? उसके
रिस्पांस देता है कि भैया वो लाइव है कि
नहीं है? वो जिंदा है कि नहीं है?
रिस्पांस देने के लायक नहीं है। तो उसको
डिसरप्ट करना सिन फ्लड अटैक
सिंक्रोनाइजेशन पैकेट्स का इतना फ्लड बना
देना इतना फ्लड [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
क्रिएट कर देना क्योंकि जब आप सिन पैकेट
भेजते हो तो सामने वाला जो है उसको क्या
करता है एसी के सन पैकेट भेजता है फिर आप
इधर से एकनॉलेज भी करते हो उस चीज को तो
वहां से ऐसा कर देना कि आप इधर से एकनॉलेज
ना करो और उसको बीच में ही रोके रखो तो
बहुत सारे सिम पैकेट्स जमा हो जाएंगे एक
बैकलग क्रिएट हो जाएगा एंड वहां पे वो
सर्वर डिसरप्ट हो जाएगी सर्विस देना बंद
कर देगी तो दिस इज़ दिस कम्स अंडर द
प्रोटोकॉल अटैक्स। तो ये एग्जांपल्स हैं।
तो DOS के टाइप्स में यहां पे हमने पहले
वॉल्यूममेट्रिक अटैक देन प्रोटोकॉल अटैक।
प्रोटोकॉल वॉलमेट्रिक के एग्जांपल है
यूडीपी फ्लड, आईसीएमपी फ्लड। प्रोटोकॉल के
जो एग्जांपल है वो सिन फ्लड एंड पिंग ऑफ़
डेथ फ्लड। पिंग ऑफ़ डेथ अटैक। अब इनके बारे
में थोड़ी-थोड़ी आपको एक्सप्लोर करनी है। बस
इतना ही मैं आपसे बोलूंगा कि अ लिटिल बिट
ऑफ़ एक्सप्लोरेशन इज़ वेरी वेरीेंट फॉर यू।
नाउ एप्लीकेशन लेयर अटैक्स इसमें क्या
होता था? स्पेशल स्पेसिफिक एप्लीकेशनेशंस
को टारगेट किया जाता है एप्लीकेशन लेयर
अटैक्स में। जैसे कि एचटीपी फ्लड लॉग इन
एंड पॉइंट अब्यूज जहां पे एसटीp मान लो
प्रोटोकॉल है उसको अटैक किया जा रहा हो।
लॉग इन एंड पॉइंट्स हैं उसको अटैक किया
जाता है। इसको डिटेक्ट करना थोड़ा हार्ड
होता है।
थोड़ी हार्ड होती है कंपेयर टू अदर
अटैक्स। बाकी ये जो एप्लीकेशन लेयर अटैक्स
है, इसका कांसेप्ट मेन ये होता है कि
स्पेसिफिक एप्लीकेशन को पॉइंट करना। अब
जैसे
कोई एप्लीकेशन है जो एसटीp पे ऑपरेट कर
रही है उसको टारगेट कर लेना। कोई
एप्लीकेशन है जो एफटीपी पे ऑपरेट कर रही
है उसको टारगेट करना। डिफरेंट टाइप ऑफ़
एप्लीकेशनेशंस को अटैक करना। बट होता क्या
है? डीडीएस अटैक ही होता है। मेन जो मोटिव
है वो क्या है? डीडीएस अटैक करना। जहां पे
अब ये डीडीएस अटैक का मैं एक कांसेप्ट भी
एक थोड़ा सा समझाऊंगा आपको। डीडीएस अटैक
में सिंपल सा एक थोड़ा सा आपको इसको मैं
विजुअलाइज करके बताना चाहता हूं। उसको आप
समझ उसको आप विजुअलाइज कर लीजिएगा प्लीज।
मैं [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] यहां पे एक
वाइट बोर्ड ओपन कर लेता हूं।
ठीक है। अब
अटैक में होता क्या है यहां पे?
जैसे कि एक हमारा
अटैकर होता है।
ठीक है? एक अटैकर हुआ अपना
इसका अपना सी एंड सी
सर्वर होता है। कमांड एंड कंट्रोल। ठीक
है? अब उसने इस अटैकर ने क्या किया है? ये
हमारा
सर्वर होता है। ठीक है?
अब इस अटैकर ने क्या किया है? सिंपल
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] सा फंडा है।
इसने बहुत सारे
मैं यहां पे ये डायग्राम का की ब्यूटी पे
मत जाइएगा। डायग्राम बहुत सुंदर है मुझे
पता है। बट प्लीज डोंट गो ऑन द ब्यूटी ऑफ़
दिस डायग्राम।
ठीक है? क्योंकि मैं माउस से बना रहा हूं।
तो जैसा बन रहा है वैसा बना दे रहा हूं।
बस ये समझ लीजिए कि ये कंप्यूटरटर्स हैं।
बता दिया ना मैंने कंप्यूटर्स हैं ये
सारे।
ठीक है?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][खांसने की आवाज़]
तो यह कंप्यूटर वन है, कंप्यूटर टू है,
कंप्यूटर थ्री है, कंप्यूटर फोर है,
कंप्यूटर फाइव है, कंप्यूटर सिक्स है। ये
कंप्यूटरटर्स हैं।
ठीक है? अब यहां पे जो अटैकर है, वो कमांड
एंड कंट्रोल के थ्रू क्या कर रहा है? उसने
ये सारे कॉम्प्रोमाइज कंप्यूटरटर्स को
कनेक्ट करके रखा है। यह सारे क्या हैं?
कॉम्प्रोमाइज्ड कंप्यूटरटर्स हैं। याद
रखिएगा।
दी ऑल आर
कॉम्रोमाइज्ड कंप्यूटरटर्स।
इनको हम बॉट्स बोल सकते हैं।
इनको हम बॉट्स बोलते हैं। बी ओ टी एस
बॉट्स। बॉट्स मतलब जो ऑटोमेटिकली काम करे।
किसी एक इंस्ट्रक्शन को फॉलो करें। या फिर
इनको हम एक और चीज बोलते हैं जिसको हम
बोलते हैं जॉमबी पीसीज।
इनको हम क्या बोलते हैं? एक और जॉम्बी
पीसेस। ठीक है? या तो हम एक और क्या बोल
सकते हैं इनको?
बॉट्स।
ठीक है? [गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़] अब
अटैकर क्या करता है बेसिकली कि ये सारे
कॉम्प्रोमाइज सिस्टम है। अटैकर ने इन सबको
ऑलरेडी कम कॉम्प्रोमाइज कर लिया है। यहां
पे अपने सॉफ्टवेयर्स इंस्टॉल कर दिए हैं।
जहां से इनको एज अ बॉट ये ट्रीट कर रहा है
और जो कमांड ये देगा अपने सीएनसी से कमांड
एंड कंट्रोल से वो कमांड ये ल्च करेंगे।
अब इसने क्या बोला कि भैया तुम्हारे पास
जो भी रिसोर्सेज हैं उन सारे रिसोर्सेज को
यूज़ करो और सब एक साथ इस सर्वर पे धावा
बोल दो। ऐसे पैकेट्स भेजो। सब इस पे
पैकेट्स भेजो, धावा बोल दो। और यह पैकेट्स
क्या हो सकते हैं? TB पर सेकंड
सॉरी सॉरी ये एस है यहां पे। पेटाबाइट्स
पर सेकंड इस तरह की स्पीड से भेजे जाते
हैं। ठीक है? थाउजेंड्स ऑफ़ 100्स ऑफ़
पेटाबाइट्स, 100्स ऑफ़ टीवीज़ पर सेकंड। अब
जब इतने पैकेट्स जब एक साथ इस सर्वर को
हिट करते हैं तो पैकेट इस सर्वर की जो
लिमिट लिमिटेशन होती है कई बार यूटिलाइज
हो जाती है। कई बार जो इसकी कैपेबिलिटी है
उससे ज्यादा पैकेट्स जब आ जाते हैं तो ये
सर्वर अपनी सर्विस देना बंद कर देता है
एंड ये डाउन हो जाता है। उस केस में जब
Facebook, Google इन सब पे भी अटैक हुए
हुए हैं काफी कई सारे पास में तो Facebook
डाउन हो गई है। सब अह Instagram डाउन हो
गई है। कई बार ऐसे चीजें हुई हैं। राइट?
सो दिस इज़ व्हाट वी कॉल एज डीडी ओएस अटैक।
डीडीओएस अटैक इसको हम बोलते हैं। ठीक है?
चलिए आई थिंक इससे ज्यादा विजुअलाइज हो
गया होगा।
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़][अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
हां। [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
अब हम यहां पे एसओसी इंडिकेटर्स की बात
करते हैं। तो सडन स्पाइक इन ट्रैफिक। सडन
ट्रैफिक में बहुत स्पाइक आ रहा है। तो
इंडिकेटर्स ये आपको बताएंगे। सेम
रिक्वेस्ट फ्रॉम मल्टीपल आईपीस। मतलब बहुत
सारी आईपी से एक ही रिक्वेस्ट आए जा रही
हैं। तो ये भी एक खतरे की घंटी है। बहुत
ज्यादा सीपीयू और मेमोरी का यूसेज हो रहा
है आपके सर्वर का। मतलब समझ जाइए कि मामला
कुछ गड़बड़ है। लेटेंसी का काफी इंक्रीज्ड
होना। लेटेंसी मतलब कि आप कितनी आपकी जो
कनेक्टिविटी है पर्टिकुलर सर्वर से जो
आपका सर्वर है उसमें
डिस्ट उसमें उसमें इंक्रीस होना कि आपकी
रिक्वेस्ट सर्वर तक बहुत लेट से पहुंच पा
रही है। तो वो जो है लेटेंसी कहलाती है
बेसिकली सिंपल लैंग्वेज में। तो उसमें
इंक्रीज इंक्रीमेंट आ रही है। मतलब आप
रिक्वेस्ट सर्वर तक पहुंच नहीं पा रही है
सही से या बहुत लेट पहुंच रही है। सर्विस
डाउन टाइम होना, सर्विस का डाउन होना। ये
सारी चीजें इंडिकेटर्स में एसओसी के आ
जाते हैं आपके। अब DOS मिटिगेशन टेक्निक्स
में देयर आर मल्टीपल वेज़ जहां से आप DS को
मिटिगेट कर सकते हैं। रेट लिमिट लगा दीजिए
कि एक पर्टिकुलर टाइम फ्रेम में इतने ही
रिक्वेस्ट सर्वर तक आ सकते हैं। उससे
ज्यादा रिक्वेस्ट आएंगे। सर्वर उसको ड्रॉप
कर देगा। चाहे कुछ भी हो जाए। तो रेट
लिमिटिंग का फीचर काफी ज्यादा यूज़ किया
जाता है वेब एप्लीकेशनेशंस की तरफ से। एंड
इन्हीं रेट लिमिट को बाईपास करके बंटीज़
अर्न करते हैं बग बंटी हंटर्स। वेब
एप्लीकेशन फायर वाल VF जिसको बोलते हैं VF
लगा देते हैं। एक फायर वाल जो सर्वर साइड
से या प्रॉक्सी रिवर्स प्रॉक्सी या जो भी
फायर वाल बोल सकते हैं आप लगाते हैं ताकि
जो सर्वर तक रिक्वेस्ट आ रही है उसकी जांच
परख हो सके। पता चल सके भैया एक सर्टेन
सेट ऑफ रूल्स तैयार किया जाता है इन वेब
एप्लीकेशन फायरव्स की तरफ से। अगर उस रूल
को फॉलो कर रही हो पैकेट तो उसको एक्सेप्ट
किया जाता है। नहीं तो उसको रिजेक्ट कर
दिया जाता है। सीडीएन क्लाउड फेयर एफएमआई
जैसे सीडीियंस यानी कि कंटेंट डिलीवरी
नेटवर्क्स का यूज़ किया जाता है कि अगर
आपकी वेबसाइट कोई फाइल कोई डॉक्यूमेंट कोई
मीडिया या किसी भी तरह का ऐसे फाइल
शेयरिंग कर रही है या डाटा मतलब पहुंचा
रही है वहां पे http http के थ्रू html
कंटेंट प्रोवाइड कर रही है तो वो आपकी
सर्वर से डायरेक्ट ना आके एक थर्ड पार्टी
सीडीए का यूज़ जैसे क्लाउड फेयर काफी
ज्यादा यूज़ कर किया जाता है फ्री ऑफ
कॉस्ट है इसलिए कई लोग उसको यूज़ करते हैं
तो तो अब क्लाउड फ्लेयर आपकी उन सारी
चीजों को हैंडल कर रहा है। उन डेटा
ट्रांसफर का काम उन hटीएमएल कंटेंट्स को
सर्व करना आपके वेबसाइट पे और आपका सर्वर
नहीं कर रहा। उनका एक कैश्ड कॉपी क्लाउड
फेयर के पास पड़ा हुआ है। कैश्ड कॉपी मतलब
एक कॉपी बैकअप कॉपी पड़ा हुआ है। और टाइम
टू टाइम वो बैकअप को रिन्यू करता रहता है।
देखता रहता है। कोई सर्वर के साइड से कोई
नई अपडेट आई है। दैट आल्सो इज़ बीन सीन इन
द हेडर्स। जो हेडर्स में हेडर्स के थ्रू
काम करते हैं। एसटीडीपी के जो रिक्वेस्ट
और रिस्पांस हेडर्स होते हैं। इसमें मैंने
एचसीडीपी के बारे में बग बाउंड्री के
क्लासेस में रिक्वेस्ट और रिस्पांस हेडर
को डील करा है। आप चाहे तो उसको देख सकते
हैं। अदरवाइज ऐसी कोई रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं
है कि उसके बिना आप नहीं समझ सकते। इसको
या आगे नहीं बढ़ सकते हैं। तो सीडीएस का
यूज़ किया जाता है ताकि वो कंटेंट्स कोई
थर्ड पार्टी सर्वर होस्ट करे और वहीं सर्व
करे। सर्वर तक जो है जाने की नौबत ना आए।
तो सर्वर आपका सम हाउस सेफ है और बहुत
ज्यादा ट्रैफिक्स को वो डील उसको करना
नहीं पड़ेगा क्योंकि सीडीएन आपकी वो सारी
चीजें हैंडल करेगी। यूजुअली सीडीियंस हैव
अ लार्ज लार्ज नंबर ऑफ अ स्पेसिफिकेशंस ऑफ
सर्वर्स जो ये खुद यूज करते हैं। काफी
ज्यादा ट्रैफिक्स
जो है हैंडल करने की इनकी क्षमता होती है।
ट्रैफिक फिल्टरिंग ट्रैफिक को फिल्टर करना
कि बकवास चीजों को हटा देना बकवास
रिक्वेस्ट को हटा देना फ़्टर करना। लोड
बैलेंसिंग लोड बैलेंसर्स यूज़ किए जाते
हैं। कई ऐसे कंपनीज़ हैं सर्वर्स हैं मतलब
जो इंस्ट जैसे Facebook, Google ये सब लोड
बैलेंस के यूज़ करते हैं कि मतलब कि दो
सर्वर्स हैं। एक सर्वर मान लो कि कैपेसिटी
उसकी फुलफिल हो गई है। तो तुरंत उसका या
ज्यादा लोड उस पे आ रहा है तो उसका लोड जो
है दूसरे सर्वर पे ट्रांसफर कर दिया जाता
है। अब वो जो है उस पर्टिकुलर लोड को
हैंडल करता है। तो दो सर्वर्स के बीच
लोडेड इज़ लोड्स जो है वो बैलेंस हो चुकी
है। एंड एक सर्वर पे बहुत ज्यादा लोड नहीं
पड़ेगा। तो इससे सर्वर आपका चंगा काम करता
है। IP ब्लॉकिंग फालतू आईपीस को ब्लॉक मार
देना। दैट्स इट। दैट्स इट। हां।
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
ये होती है आपकी आईपी ब्लॉकिंग। दिस इज़
कॉल्ड DOS के मिटिगेशन। डीडीएस के
मिटिगेशन के टेक्निक्स ये सारे हैं। इन
दोनों के बीच के अगर हम डिफरेंस की बात
करें बहुत देखो ये दोनों अलग-अलग तरह की
चीज़ हैं। एमआईटीएम इज़ अ डिफरेंट थिंग।
डीडीओएस इज़ अ बट आपसे इंटरव्यू में पूछा
जा सकता है कि दोनों के बीच का डिफरेंस
क्या है? गोल के कॉन्टेक्स्ट में बात करें
तो एमआईटीए में डाटा को इंटरसेप्ट किया
जाता है। DOS में सर्विस को डिसरप्ट किया
जाता है। वाह क्या राइमिंग है। डेटा को
इंटरसेप्ट किया जाता है। सर्विस को
डिसररप्ट किया जाता है। इंपैक्ट के केस
में बात करें तो डेटा की चुराई होती है।
डेटा थफ्ट किया जाता है। यहां पे सर्विस
की चुराई होती है। सर्विस को ठप कर दिया
जाता है। विजिबिलिटी की बात करें तो इस ये
स्टिल्थ ही होती है। थोड़ा सा स्टिल्थ एक
चीज है और ये बहुत नॉइज़ ये बहुत ज्यादा
नॉइज़ क्रिएट करता है। डॉट डॉट डॉट डॉट
डॉट्स अटैक हो गई। डिटेक्शन यह थोड़ा हार्ड
है। इसका डिटेक्शन थोड़ा ईज़ है इस अटैक का
क्योंकि सर्विस आउटज़ हो जाती है तो थोड़ा
ईज़ी है। इसमें जब तक कि पता नहीं चले कि
भाई चुराया जा रहा है तब तक डिटेक्ट करना
मुश्किल है। ये टाइप क्या है? इसकी इसमें
सीआईए ट्रायड की कॉन्फिडेंशियलिटी पे अटैक
किया जाता है। एमआईटीए मैन इन द मिडिल
क्योंकि डाटा को चुरा लिया जाता है। तो
डाटा जिस जगह पहुंचनी चाहिए वहां ना पहुंच
के किसी और को भी मिल रही है। तो
कॉन्फिडेंशियलिटी पे अटैक हो रहा है। और
डीडीओएस में अवेलेबिलिटी पे अटैक होता है।
डेटा एक जेन्युइन यूजर को अवेलेबल होना
चाहिए। वो अवेलेबल नहीं हो पा रही है। तो
ये अवेलेबिलिटी का शॉर्टेज है। तो
अवेलेबिलिटी पे अटैक हो रहा है। समझ में आ
गया होगा यहां पे। हैशिंग जो होती है
उसमें इंटीग्रिटी की बात होती है।
एमआईटीएम में कॉन्फिडेंशियलिटी की बात
होती है। डीडीओएस में अवेलेबिलिटी की बात
होती है। तो साइबर सिक्योरिटी में साइबर
अटैक में एथिकल हैकिंग या हैकिंग जो भी
बोलना है उसमें जितने भी अटैक्स होते हैं
वो किसी ना किसी सीआईए ट्राइड को डिनोट
करते ही करते हैं। चाहे वो
कॉन्फिडेंशियलिटी को करते हो, अवेलेबिलिटी
को करते हो या इंटीग्रिटी को करते हो। अगर
हर अटैक को आप सीआईए से जोड़ देते हैं और
उसी का कॉन्टेक्स्ट में समझने की कोशिश
करते हैं और उसी कॉन्टेक्स्ट में आंसर
करते हैं तो आपका आंसर ज्यादा
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
टेक्निकल होगा, ज्यादा डायरेक्ट टू द
पॉइंट होगा और इंटरव्यूअर को उसको समझने
में भी मजा आएगा क्योंकि उसको समझ में आ
जाएगा कि आपको ये चीजें पता है। दैट्स इट।
ठीक है? ओके। अब आते हैं एसोसिएशन
एनालिस्ट के थिंकिंग के ऊपर में। क्या है
भैया यह? तो देखो एज एसोसिएशन एनालिस्ट
अगर आप यह देखते हैं सस्िशियस सर्टिफिकेट
वार्निंग यूज़र्स लॉग इन हाईजैक का कंप्लेन
कर रहे हैं। डीएनएस मिसमैच तो यह समझिए यह
मैन इन द मिडिल अटैक का केस है। अगर आपको
वेबसाइट डाउन दिख रही है, ट्रैफिक में
स्पाइक दिख रहा है, सर्वर काफी ओवरलोडेड
दिख रहा है, तो आप समझिए यह डीडीओएस का
केस है। दैट्स इट। एज़ एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट,
दिस इज़ द थिंग दैट यू आर गोइंग टू सी एंड
यू आर गोइंग टू ऑब्ज़र्व। एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट
L1 फर्स्ट लाइन ऑफ़ डिफेंस तो है ही बट
ऑब्ज़रवेशन पावर बहुत ज्यादा होना चाहिए
उनका। एल1 की तरह ऑब्जरवेशन अगर आपका है,
अगर आपका ऑब्जरवेशन उस तरह का हो जा रहा
है, तो आपको एल1 बनने से कोई रोक नहीं
सकता है और आप एक परफेक्ट एल1 कैंडिडेट हो
जाएंगे। साथ ही आप एक अच्छे एल1 एनालिस्ट
यानी कि जूनियर सिक्योरिटी एनालिस्ट भी बन
सकते हैं और उसी में अपग्रेडेशन करते-करते
आप अपना डोमेन भी चेंज कर सकते हैं। रेड
टीमिंग में जा सकते हैं। पर्पल में जा
सकते हैं। जो भी टीमिंग है सब में आप टीम
टीम कर सकते हैं। कोई टेंशन की बात नहीं
है। आपको बस स्किल आपके अंदर होना चाहिए।
एक प्रॉपर तो स्किल के लिए आपको समझना
होना चाहिए। समझना समझ आना चाहिए कि भाई
क्या एग्जैक्टली हो रहा है? कोई अटैक हो
रहा है तो वो क्यों हो रहा है? कैसे हो
रहा है? इससे बच कैसे सकते हैं? इसको
काउंटर मुझे कैसे कर सकते हैं? दैट्स इट।
खत्म कहानी। ये होती है पूरी आपकी एलवन
थिंकिंग। अब यहां पे फिलहाल ये तो चीज़
स्लाइड तो मेरी खत्म हो गई। बट यहां पे
मैं आपको एक चीज़ दिखाने की कोशिश करूंगा।
अ इन केस ऑफ लाइक जब ट्रैफिक की बात करते
हैं, एमआईटीएम की बात करते हैं तो ट्रैफिक
को इंटरसेप्ट किया जाता है। इसके लिए
टूल्स का यूज़ किया जाता है। एक बहुत अच्छी
टूल आती है जिसको हम बोलते हैं वायरशार्क।
ठीक है?
मैं यहां पे वायरशार्क के डेमोंस्ट्रेशन
के लिए नहीं आपको दिखा रहा। मैं आपको बस
एक चीज़ बस ओवरव्यू दे रहा हूं कि किस
तरीके से ये चीजें होती हैं। वायरशार्क एक
टूल है जो कि बिल्कुल फ्री ऑफ़ कॉस्ट आपको
मिल जाएगा। आप सिंपल सर्च करेंगे वाशार्क
डाउनलोड एंड इट विल गो टू द इट विल लिस्ट
डाउन द वेबसाइट ऑफ़ वशक जहां पे आप आके
Windows का एक 64 वर्जन डाउनलोडर इंस्टॉलर
आप इंस्टॉल कर सकते हैं। ARM 64 इंस्टॉलर
भी है। पोर्टेबल भी है। MacOS का
यूनिवर्सल डिस्क इमेज भी है। Untटू
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] का भी है एंड
जो भी है यहां पे ओल्ड रिलीज़ भी है। तो आप
Windows का कर लीजिएगा। इंस्टॉल कर
लीजिएगा। बाकी सारे जो सॉफ्टवेयर्स है
उसको डबल क्लिक नेक्स्ट नेक्स्ट कर करके।
उसके बाद आप जब ओपन करेंगे तो आपको यहां
पे अपना नेटवर्क यूज़ करना होता है। जो भी
आप अप्टर यूज़ करें जैसे आप Wi-Fi यूज़ कर
रहे हैं तो मैं यहां पे Wi-Fi कोई और यूज़
कर रहे हैं या कोई और नेटवर्क को आप
इथरनेट को यूज़ कर रहे हैं तो वो कर लीजिए।
VMware के साथ कैप्चर करना चाहते हैं वो
कर लीजिए। डबल क्लिक करेंगे तो इस नेटवर्क
का जो स्कैनिंग है वो चालू हो जाता है।
मतलब ये नेटवर्क के अंदर अब जो भी आप अब
आपने वायरशार्क को ऑन कर दिया। वायरशार्क
आप का बीच का अब काम कर रहा है। मतलब आपके
और इंटरनेट के बीच जो भी बातचीत होंगी
उसको यह कैप्चर करेगा। उन पैकेट्स को
कैप्चर करेगा और आपके सामने ला के रख
देगा। सो दिस इज़ अब मैं इसको यहां पे
स्टॉप कर देता हूं। तो यहां पे ये कंप्लीट
स्टॉप हो जाएगा। अब मैं अगर किसी चीज से
कम्युनिकेट करने की कोशिश करता हूं। जैसे
मैं मान लो कि किसी भी वेबसाइट से
कम्युनिकेट कर रहा हूं। मैं टेस्ट पीएपी
देखता हूं कि इफ इट इज़ वर्किंग ऑ नॉट।
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़][अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
कई बार यह काम नहीं करता है।
हम अभी यह वैसे ही आई थिंक नहीं काम कर
रही है। टेस्ट एएसपी देख लेते हैं।
हम हम
ये भी नहीं कर रही है। लेट्स सपोज मान लो
कोई सा भी एक नेटवर्क हो। मैं यहां पे मान
के चलता हूं।
लेट्स गो टू द
हां चलो मैं चलता हूं मनी कंट्रोल पे
ठीक है मैं मनी कंट्रोल वेबसाइट ओपन कर
लेता हूं लेट्स सी
मैं यहां पे आया अब मान लो कि मैं यहां पे
आके लॉग इन कर रहा हूं यहां पे यहां पे
लॉग इन का ऑप्शन सॉरी
लॉग इन का ऑप्शन है मैं लॉग इन पे चलता
हूं अब यहां पे लॉग इन विद पासवर्ड अब मैं
यहां पे ईमेल पासवर्ड डालूंगा। तो जब यहां
पे मैं पासवर्ड ईमेल पासवर्ड डालूंगा तो
देखो यहां पे मनी कंट्रोल का यहां पे पहले
तो हम इसकी थोड़ी सी आईपी देख लेते हैं।
एग्जैक्टली इसकी आईपी अभी हमारे पास क्या
निकल के आ रही है। ठीक है? तो इसके लिए
मैं पिंग करूंगा कंट्रोल वी करूंगा। एंड
यहां पे मनी कंट्रोल की आईपी मैं देखने की
कोशिश करूंगा। व्हाट इज द आईपी? बिहाइंड
दिस डोमेन। सो यहां IP वर्जन सिक्स मिल
रहा है। मैं वर्जन 4 के लिए देखता हूं।
सो इट्स द 23
यह आईपी मेरे पास आ गई है। राइट? तो अब
मैं यहां पे लॉग इन जब कर रहा हूं। आई एम
गोइंग टू फॉर द लॉग इन केस। मैं लॉग इन
विद पासवर्ड कर रहा हूं। मैंने यहां पे
मान लो लेट्स सपोज़ कि मैं यहां पे इसकी
अभी तो स्टॉप है ये। राइट? इसको हम वापस
से स्टार्ट करेंगे। यहां पे मैं एंटर कर
देता हूं। मान लो टीम डिफ़्रॉनिक्स डाल
दिया मैंने। पासवर्ड में यहां पे मैंने अ
कुछ भी डाल दिया।
ऑब्वियस सी बात है रॉन्ग पासवर्ड है। लॉग
इन करने से पहले मैं यहां पे इंटरसेप्टर
जो है उसको स्टार्ट करूंगा। मतलब अगेन जो
स्कैनिंग स्टार्ट करूंगा कंटिन्यू विदाउट
सेविंग। ठीक है? मैंने यहां पे कंटिन्यू
किया यहां पे। ये अपना जो भी है चल रहा है
यहां पे। अब मैं यहां पे लॉग इन कर रहा
हूं। लॉग इन करने के बाद ये बताएगा
यूजरनेम रॉन्ग पासवर्ड आ रहा है। ठीक है?
तो 28 समथिंग कुछ IPपी एड्रेस थी अब यहां
पे। अब यहां पे जो आईपीस यहां पे चल रही
हैं। ये आईपीस IP वर्जन सिक्स भी आ सकती
हैं। IP वर्जन 4 भी आ सकता है। व्हाटएवर
इट कैन बी। IP वर्जन सिक्स भी आपकी आ रही
तो IP वर्जन सिक्स भी हमने निकाला था यहां
पे। इसकी IP वर्जन सिक्स कुछ इस तरीके से
यह वाली IP वर्जन सिक्स थी। राइट? तो आप
जब देखोगे यहां पे तो बहुत सारी रिक्वेस्ट
जाएंगी। बहुत सारी रिक्वेस्ट। अब मैं यहां
पे IP अ एड्रेस इज़ इक्वल टू अगर मैं सेम
IP डालूं। आईपी वज़न
फोर वाला। तो देखते हैं यहां पे यह कैप्चर
हुआ है कि नहीं। फोर का हुआ है कि नहीं।
सिक्स पे हुआ है। इट कैन बी ऑफ़ सिक्स। तो
लेट्स
लेट्स चेक विद द सिक्स जो सिक्स है। फोर
पर तो यह कैप्चर नहीं हो रहा। फोर इट्स
नॉट देयर।
IP वर्जन सिक्स एड्रेस दिया हमने। एंड
यहां पे हम IP वर्जन सिक्स एड्रेस का एक
बार देख लेते हैं। इज़ देयर इज़ सम ट्रैफिक
ऑ नॉट। ऐसा कुछ कैप्चर अगर हुआ होगा तो।
सो अगर देखो अभी यहां पे कुछ हमें शो नहीं
कर रहा बट अगर अभी यहां पे कुछ भी कैप्चर
हुआ रहता उस पर्टिकुलर IPपी एड्रेस से
रिलेटेड या कुछ भी कम्युनिकेशन कैप्चर हुई
रहती है तो यहां पे आपको वो दिखा देता अगर
मान लो मेरे को TCP का देखना है TCP अ
कनेक्टिविटी का क्या है तो यहां पे जितने
भी प्रोटोकॉल TCP वाले प्रोटोकॉल वाले
डेटा है वो आपको यहां पे देखने को मिल
जाएंगे। राइट? यहां पे आपको देखने को
मिलेगा। क्योंकि अभी ये इतने सारे पैकेज
जनरेट कर रहा है। इसका सबसे सिंपल सा सबसे
बड़ा रीज़न क्या है? कि अभी हमारा YouTube
का लाइव स्ट्रीमिंग चल रहा है जो कि
यूडीपी प्रोटोकॉल पे काम करती है। एंड
यहां पे बेसिकली ये जो मतलब टीसीp यूडीपी
दोनों ही इसमें ऑपरेट होते हैं। लेकिन
यहां पे YouTube जब हम चला रहे हैं लाइव
स्ट्रीम कर रहे हैं तो इसकी वजह से ये
ट्रैफिक का जो डेटा है वो इतनी ज्यादा
मतलब अ
वॉल्यूम में आपको ये डेटाज़ या बार-बार ये
चलते हुए दिख रहे हैं। जब आप अपने सिस्टम
पे करेंगे नॉर्मली जब बिना किसी चीज के तो
यहां पे बहुत सिंपल सैंपल सा डेटा मिलेगा।
किसी भी डेटा को जब आप कैप्चर करेंगे
पकड़ेंगे तो यहां पे कुछ यहां पे फील्स
होती हैं। राइट? जैसे फ्रेम होते हैं,
इथरनेट, इंटरनेट प्रोटोकॉल का, ट्रांसमिशन
कंट्रोल का, ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर सिक्योरिटी
का सब कुछ। इनको जब एक्सपेंड करेंगे तो
इनमें अलग-अलग डिटेल्स मिलती हैं आपको। अब
जैसे ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर सिक्योरिटी में
आपको स्ट्रीम इंडेक्स का नंबर मिल जाता है
एंड वर्जन वगैरह मिल जाती है सारे। ये
हमारे उतने इंपॉर्टेंट नहीं है।
ट्रांसमिशन कंट्रोल प्रोटोकॉल में आपको
मिल जाता है बेसिकली कि सोर्स पोर्ट इस
पर्टिकुलर कम्युनिकेशन का क्या था? मतलब
सोर्स पोर्ट कहां किस पोर्ट से
कम्युनिकेशन निकली है? मतलब आपने जो
कनेक्ट किया उसका पोर्ट क्या था?
डेस्टिनेशन पोर्ट क्या था? किस पोर्ट से
वो कनेक्ट हो रही है? उसके बाद यहां पे
आपको निकल के आता है टीसीp सेगमेंट जो
आपकी रिक्वेस्ट है सेगमेंट जो है उसकी
लेंथ कितनी है? बाइट्स में आपकी सीक्वेंस
नंबर आपका निकल कर आता है। उसी तरीके से
एकनॉलेजमेंट नंबर एक निकल कर आता है। देन
यहां पे अलग-अलग जो फ्लैग्स और विंडज़ के
जो नंबर्स होते हैं वो सारी चीज़ आपको निकल
कर आती है यहां पे। एंड देयर आर डिफरेंट
काइंड ऑफ टीसीपी फ्लैग्स जिसके बारे में
आपको डिटेल होती है। जैसे कि सीन एसी के
अका
एसी अ सीन फिन या जो भी आपके टीसीपी
फ्लैग्स वहां पे यूज़ हो रहे हैं पर्टिकुलर
चीज के लिए वो यहां पे आपको दिखने लगते
हैं। तो ये वायरशक टूल्स जो है इसमें जो
इसमें अलग-अलग तरह के पैकेट्स को एनालाइज़
किया जाता है। देयर आर डिफरेंट काइंड्स ऑफ़
पैकेजेस जो अह हम एनालिसिस करने के लिए
वशक जैसे टूल्स का इस्तेमाल करते हैं। अब
यहां पे इनका जब यह पैकेट्स आपके एनालाइज़
हो जाते हैं, मान लो कि इफ़ यू आर अह
एनालाइज़िंग सम काइंड ऑफ़ पैकेज, राइट? अब
आपने पैकेज को एनालाइज़ कर लिया। अब आप इन
पैकेज को सेव भी कर सकते हो। जैसे मैं अगर
यहां पे करूंगा यहां पे मैं यहां पे पहले
स्टॉप कर देता हूं इसको। ठीक है? स्टॉप कर
दिया मैंने। अब मैं अगर चाहता हूं तो इसको
मैं इस पूरे पैकेट को सेव कर सकता हूं।
मैं सेव एस करूंगा ना तो यहां पे पता है
ये पिककैप का एक पिककैप एनg या तो पिककैप
ये एक्सटेंशन के साथ आप सेव कर सकते हैं।
एंड इस पिकैप फाइल को आप किसी भी किसी भी
तरह के पैकेट एनालाइजर टूल में इंपोर्ट
करके एनालाइज़ फर्दर कर सकते हैं। या
वायरशार्क में ही फर्दर आप बाद में भी
एनालाइज़ कर सकते हो उन पैकेट्स को जो भी
पैकेट आपने यहां पे कैप्चर किया है। इस
तरीके से एनालिसिस होती है पैकेट्स की जो
पैकेट्स होते हैं। हर चीज पैकेट है। जो भी
ट्रांसमिशन हो रही है, डेटा का क्रॉसओवर
हो रहा है, डेटा सेंड रिसीव हो रही है, वो
सब पैकेट्स का कमाल है। हर जगह पैकेट्स ही
हैं आपका। याद रखिएगा। तो यहां पे भी वही
आपके पैकेट्स हैं जो आपको यहां पे दिख रहे
हैं। अब यहां पे पॉसिबिलिटी क्या है भैया?
कि आप यहां पे कैप्चर नहीं हुई है वो।
दैट्स दैट्स व्हाट द पॉसिबिलिटी कुड बी।
मैं यहां पे अगर कंटिन्यू विदाउट सेविंग
करूं। मैं स्टार्ट कर दूं और मैं यहां पे
क्या करता हूं? मैं यहां पे डेफ्रोनिक्स
ओपन कर लेता हूं। मान लो या आई एम गोइंग
टू ओपन Flipkart।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ऐसे ओपन कर लिया मैंने Flipkart का। मैंने
यहां पर इसका लॉग इन ऐसे ओपन कर लिया।
राइट? कुछ इस तरीके से। अब मैं अगर इसकी
आईपी को देखूं Flipkart.com की वी कैन सी
इफ दैट इज़ बीइंग
प्रॉपर्ली कैप्चरर्ड। सो पिंग करता हूं
मैं। देखता हूं ip6 है। ip4 दे रहे हैं
ये। तो मेरे पास 103 एआईपी की हम
ये आईपी आई है। अब अगर मैं यहां पे IP
एड्रेस चेक करूं
इफ देयर इज़ सम काइंड ऑफ़ कैप्चर तो आप
दिखेगा आपको यहां पे कि कैप्चर हुई है
यहां पे। अब मैं इसको स्टॉप कर देता हूं।
अब मैंने आप देखा मैंने Flipkart पे किया।
सो व्हाट आई डीड? Flipkart ओपन किया। यहां
पे आपको दिख आपको यहां पे दिखेगा। जैसे
मैंने Flipkart का ट्रैफिक कैप्चर किया
यहां पे। तो यहां पे लॉग इन पे मैं गया
एंड आई कैप्चर्ड इट। राइट? अब यहां पे
आपको दिखेगा पहले में यहां पे नंबर्स होते
हैं। सीक्वेंस नंबर्स होते हैं जो कि मतलब
कि 9982 997 मतलब ऊपर से नीचे की तरफ आपको
सीक्वेंस नंबर दिखेंगे। ये लास्ट सीक्वेंस
के ये सारे हैं। अब आपको
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] यहां पे दिखेगा
सोर्स आईपी। तो ये जो सोर्स आईपी आपको दिख
रही है ये जो है ये मेरी पर्टिकुलर आईपी
जिससे रिक्वेस्ट जा रही है। ठीक है? अब ये
जो आपको दिख रही है 192 168.1.4 ये कौन सी
आईपी है? 1.4 ये मेरी आईपी है। मैं आपको
दिखा देता हूं। मैं आपको IP कॉन्फिग करके
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
यहां पे दिखा देता हूं।
वाई-फाई में देखो 1926.1.4
ये मेरी आईपी है। तो ये ये आपका
दिख रहा है यहां पे सोर्स यानी कि मेरे
नेटवर्क से ट्रैफिक जा रहा है। डेस्टिनेशन
कहां गया है? 103243290
जो कि किसकी आईपी है?
10324393290
Flipkart की IP है। तो रिक्वेस्ट मेरे IP
से Flipkart का IP गई है। एक TCP
प्रोटोकॉल का यूज़ हो रहा है। लेंथ 54
बाइट्स की यहां पे इनफो यहां पे दी गई है।
एंड यहां पे आपको दिख रहा है कि एक
एकनॉलेजमेंट आई है। यह मैंने एकनॉलेज किया
क्योंकि मैं क्लाइंट हूं ना। तो आई हैव
एकनॉलेज्ड। बट मैं जब रिक्वेस्ट करूंगा तो
मैं सीन भी पैकेट भेजूंगा। आई विल सेंड अ
सीन पैकेट आल्सो। ठीक है? तो मैं आपको
यहां पे ऊपर दिखाता हूं। देखो यहां पे ये
देखो मैंने 192 168.14 तो sin sin एसीके
एंड एस एकनॉलेज ऐसे पैकेट्स जाते हैं। तो
पहले मैंने आपको कई लोग जो हैकिंग वगैरह
जानते हैं थोड़ा बहुत पढ़ा होगा मेरे से
क्लासेस फ्री वाली भी देखी होंगी। तो
क्लाइंट एंड सर्वर के बीच में क्या होता
है? सीन
सन एसी के
एंड देन एकनॉलेजमेंट। तो यह सन जो है यह
क्लाइंट भेजता है सन एसी के
यह सर्वर भेजता है एंड देन एसी के एकनॉलेज
की जाती है क्लाइंट के तरफ से कि भैया हां
रिस्पांस मिल गया इसको हम थ्री वे हैंडशक
बोलते हैं
थ्री वे हैंडशक हम इसको बोलते हैं। ठीक
है? दैट्स इट।
करेक्ट।
ओके? तो यहां पे अब पहला जो कम्युनिकेशन
हुआ तो क्या हुआ टीसीp बट यहां पे सन
पैकेट भेजी गई है सन मतलब मेरी तरफ से
रिक्वेस्ट गई है वहां पे फिर सर्वर के
साइड से एकनॉलेज भी हुआ होगा जब देखो यहां
पे सर्वर ने अब सर्वर सोर्स है यानी सर्वर
मुझे रिप्लाई कर रहा है डेस्टिनेशन को विद
द एसी के तो ये जो कम्युनिकेशन है
Flipkart जैसे Flipkart में हमने की ये
कम्युनिकेशन हो रही है। देखो यहां पे
क्लाइंट ने यहां पे क्या किया? यहां पे
मैंने क्या किया था? यहां पे टीएलएस यूज़
हो रहा है। ट्रांसपोर्ट लेस सिक्योरिटी।
क्लाइंट ने बोला हेलो हेलो भैया। हेलो
हेलो देखो यहां पे Flipkart। अभी इसमें
कम्युनिकेशन को अगर मैं पढ़ने जाऊं तो मैं
यहां पे दिखाऊंगा तुम्हें ट्रांसमिशन
कंट्रोल प्रोटोकॉल में। सोर्स एंड
डेस्टिनेशन पोर्ट आपको दिख गया।
डेस्टिनेशन पोर्ट आपका Flipkart का पोर्ट
है। तो यहां से आपको कनेक्ट हुआ। हमने
हमने कनेक्ट किया यहां पे। यहां पे इसकी
सारी डिटेल्स हैं। इन डिटेल्स के ऊपर
ज्यादा नहीं जाएंगे क्योंकि इसकी कोई
रिक्वायरमेंट है नहीं। आपको समझ में आएगा
नहीं एंड आपके लिए उतनी रिक्वायरमेंट भी
फिलहाल नहीं है। तो यहां पे इंटरनेट
प्रोटोकॉल वर्जन को जब आप देखेंगे तो यहां
पे आपको देखने को मिलेगा सोर्स एड्रेस
आपका डेस्टिनेशन एड्रेस आपके Flipkart का
ये यहां पे आपको देखने को मिल जाएगा। ठीक
है? ये टीडीटीएल वैल्यू होती है 128 जो
मैंने डिस्कस बहुत बार करा है आप लोगों के
साथ। ये सब अभी आपको नहीं भी जानते हो।
कोई टेंशन लेने वाली बात नहीं। हड़बड़ाना
नहीं है कि भैया अरे हम तो कुछ नहीं
जानते। यहां पे आप देखोगे डेटा यहां पे
दिखेगी। डाटा स्ट्रीम जो है ये यहां पे
आपको Flipkart एंड ये सब चीजें दिखेंगी।
ठीक है? तो पैकेट्स को रीड यहां पे किया
जाता है। इस तरीके से यू कैन रीड द
पैकेट्स। यू कैन यूज़ डिफरेंट काइंड ऑफ़
वायरशार्क फिल्टर्स। ये जो क्वेरी पास की
है मैंने इसको फ़्टर्स बोलते हैं। वायरशक
के फिल्टर्स होते हैं। तो देयर आर
थाउजेंड्स ऑफ़ वायरशाक फ़िल्टर्स जो आपको
थोड़ा प्रैक्टिस करते-करते समझ में आ
जाएगा। याद भी हो जाता है। अब तो यहां पे
ये लोग दे भी जैसे आईपी से रिलेटेड करना
है तो IP लिखो और उससे रिलेटेड सारे
फ़्टर्स आपको आ जाते हैं। ठीक है? होस्ट से
रिलेटेड कोई फ़िल्टर है तो उसको आप यूज़ कर
सकते हो। TCP फ्लैग के थ्रू कर सकते हो।
कोई यूडीपी फ्लैग का कोई है तो उसको यूज़
कर सकते हो। दे आर डिफरेंट काइंड ऑफ़
इटर्स। तो इस तरीके से वाशक का यूज़ किया
जाता है पैकेट्स को फ़्टर करने के लिए,
पैकेट्स को कैप्चर करने के लिए एंड
पैकेट्स को रीड करने के लिए। एंड इसी
तरीके से पैकेट्स को रीड करके समझा जाता
है कि कम्युनिकेशन कैसे हो रही है एक
नेटवर्क से दूसरे नेटवर्क एक डिवाइस का
दूसरे डिवाइस से कम्युनिकेशन। ठीक है?
ओके। [गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
उसके लिए गौरव आप हमारा डीएई बग बंटी
नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी यह प्लेलिस्ट देख
लीजिए।
ठीक है?
सो, यह समझ में आ गई आप लोगों को? मजा
आया? यह समझ में आया आप लोगों को? अब
वायरशार्क जब मैंने बताया, तो वायरशार्क
के ऊपर थोड़ी सी नॉलेज, थोड़ी सी
एक्सप्लोरेशन कर लीजिएगा। क्या होता है,
कैसे काम करता है? वायरशार्क में किस
तरीके से चीजें होती हैं, कैप्चरिंग होती
है। बहुत ज्यादा डीप नहीं जाना है। बहुत
ज्यादा घुसना नहीं है। कोई आपकी
रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं पड़ेगी। अभी अभी के लिए
कोई रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं है। ठीक है? बस
ओवरव्यू हल्का ले लीजिएगा। सो, आर यू
गेटिंग गाइस? डीड यू गेट एवरीथिंग? सभी
लोगों को समझ में आया इतना?
सभी लोग समझ समझ पा रहे हैं। इसको समझ समझ
पा रहे थे। बता दीजिए एक बार।
एवरीबडी प्लीज आंसर।
ठीक है।
ठीक है। काफी लोग समझ चुके हैं।
ओके। अच्छी बात है। क्लास बहुत अमेजिंग
था। आई होप सो कि सारी क्लासेस अमेजिंग
लगे आप लोगों को और ऐसे ही जाएं।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ओके। एकदम अच्छे से। बढ़िया है। ठीक है।
बढ़िया है गाइस। मैंने जो पहले बोला था कर
लीजिएगा वो चीज जरूर कीजिएगा आप लोग याद
से
यूनिक यूनिक कमेंट्स कीजिएगा 200 प्लस
नहीं तो फिर वो फिर काउंट हो जाता है फिर
फायदा नहीं है एंड फॉलो कर लीजिएगा
WhatsApp चैनल को और WhatsApp ग्रुप को
ज्वाइन कर लीजिएगा सर आप बहुत अच्छा
समझाते हो थैंक यू सर आपका हर सेशन बेस्ट
होता है थैंक यू गौरव आई होप कि आप बढ़िया
से उसको फॉलो अप करें
ओके टॉप फैंस की एक बार लिस्ट में आ जाते
हैं गाइस। अ लेट्स गो टू द टॉप फेंस लिस्ट
एंड यहां पे अगेन हमारे टॉप फेंस लिस्ट
में
अ देयर इज़ अलबेरूनी गीकेएस रक्स जगत
गुरुस्वामी अमित यादव प्रदीप आदि कीट
आदित्य गौरव आदित्य निशा रोबोट मिस्टर
रोबोट शाहलीम केशव अशोक अ भूत भूत बांग
प्रशांत अश्विन शुभम यश रूज दीपक नमन गैबर
बैक रैंडम यो पीतांबर यशराज मिस्टर सचिन
फोरस्कल सुजॉय
रोहित रोहित कैंथर कॉनके पता नहीं क्या
लिखा है साइबर रक्षा टेकाय शुभम
यान इकबाल बबलू वीरेंद्र
मिस्टर जट टॉप ब्रोकिन वास उस्मान अली
मिस्टर विजय सोलंकी सुमित चौधरी कंचन आशीष
अमरीश एंड मुजनैन एंड ओके सो थैंक यू वेरी
मच गाइस फॉर बीइंग हियर फॉर बीइंग इन द
टॉप चैट लिस्ट टॉप फाइनलिस्ट एंड आई रियली
एप्रिशिएट जॉइनिंग दीज़ सेशंस क्योंकि ये
सेशंस आपके लिए काफी काफी मजेदार होने
वाले हैं आने वाले टाइम में आप जब एसओसी
एल वन बन के निकलेंगे तो सबसे ज्यादा
प्राउड मुझे होगा। बिलीव मी आपसे ज्यादा
मुझे होगा। एंड मैं उसी हिसाब से आपके लिए
सेशन लाते लेते आ रहा हूं और लाता रहूंगा।
बट आपका एक जो काम है वो जरूर कीजिए। सेशन
को शेयर जरूर कीजिए उन लोगों के बीच जिनको
इसकी जरूरत है। प्लीज अपने तक बस मत रखिए।
एंड इससे हमें भी सपोर्ट मिलता है,
इनकरेजमेंट मिलती है जब ज्यादा लोग आते
हैं। ज्यादा लोगों तक पहुंचती है। मैंने
देखा था कई लोगों को सेशन शेयर करते हैं
Telegram वगैरह पे भी ऐसे WhatsApp पे भी।
तो अच्छा लगता है। आप लोग शेयर करते रहिए।
लोगों को बताइए इसके बारे में। इसको पूरा
फैला दीजिए। बस यही मैं चाहता हूं।
जाते-जाते लाइक ठोक के जाना। चैनल पे अगर
नए होते हो तो सब्सक्राइब ठोक के जाना।
बेल आइकन को ऑन कर देना। नोटिफिकेशन आपको
मिल जाए। दैट्स इट। ठीक है?
बहुत अभी तो क्लासेस बहुत हैं।
आई एम शेयरिंग माय स्टडी विद डिफ्रॉनिक्स
ऑन Lindin नो फीडबैक।
मैंने आपके
देखे हैं। जरूरी नहीं है कि मैं लाइक करूं
तभी आप शेयर करेंगे। आप मेरे लाइक के लिए
शेयर मत कीजिए। आप अपने लिए शेयर कीजिए।
ठीक है?
अ
सर एल बरूनी को आपके कंटेंट से प्यार हो
गया है। आपसे क्या बात है एलबीनी कहां से
हैं आप? एलबूनी बताइए इंडिया से तो आप
नहीं लगते हैं। आप कहां से हैं बताइए? कोई
बात नहीं मिस्टर रोहित
सर मैं एसओसी 111 वीडियो देखता हूं बट
नेटवर्किंग एंड बेसिक नॉलेज ना होने के
कारण बहुत दिक्कत होता है। सब चीज बेसिक
तरीके से बता रहा हूं मैं आपको। कोई जरूरत
नहीं है आपको बेसिक नॉलेज की। सब चीजें
मैं बता रहा हूं। एंड अगर फिर भी आपको
लेना है बेसिक नॉलेज तो हमारे डिफ्रॉनिक्स
एकडमी पे नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी की प्लेलिस्ट
है। डीईएई की प्लेलिस्ट है, बग बंटी की
प्लेलिस्ट है। सबको देखते रहिए पैरेलली।
राइट
ओके अल्बनी अच्छा पाकिस्तान से हैं आप?
लाहौर पाकिस्तान चलिए बढ़िया है।
ओके यस।
ओके गाइस। सो थैंक यू वेरी मच।
अ फॉर अटेंडिंग दिस सेशन गाइस। जाते-जाते
लाइक ठोक के एंड सब्सक्राइब कर दीजिएगा
एंड शेयर कर दीजिए दोस्तों के बीच। इस
वीडियो को शेयर कीजिए। कई लोग शेयर नहीं
कर पाते हैं तो उनको भी मैं बोलता हूं
शेयर कीजिए। हमारा बेनिफिट है उसमें हमारे
कई थाउजेंड्स ऑफ पीपल गेट टू सी दिस काइंड
ऑफ वीडियोस। तो उनका बेनिफिट है। तो उनको
जरूर शेयर कीजिएगा। थैंक यू वेरी मच इस
क्लास के लिए। मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट क्लास
में बहुत जल्द गाइस। तो अभी के लिए सभी को
टाटा बाय-ब गुड नाइट। शुभ रात्रि। मिलते
हैं अगले क्लास में। धन्यवाद।